change donc on va on va débuter les les
travaux de de notre commission c'est la
première séquence d'audition en
auditionnant monsieur Guillaume deobri
c'est comme ça qu'on dit monsieur vous
êtes avocat et maître de conférence en
droit public Monsieur Nicolas
meyan vous êtes ingénieur spécialiste de
l'énergie et vous avez notamment été
conseiller scientifique à France
stratégie Monsieur Thomas Lerin Carlin
vous êtes directeur de programme
investissement climat européen
cleantetech à l'Institut pour le climat
i4ce et Monsieur Jacques Percebois vous
êtes professeur émérite à l'Université
de Montpellier directeur du Centre de
recherche en économie et droit de
l'énergie le creden et auteur de très
nombreux ouvrages sur
l'électricité qui font notre
bonheur quand on essaie de de comprendre
comment les choses marchent parce que
c'est pas simple donc le le la partie
formelle en ce début de d'audition donc
avant de vous donner la parole je me
dois de vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête est pasible des peines prévu
aux articles
434-13
434-1
434-1 du code pénal je vous invite à
prêter serement de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité en levant la main
droite et en disant je le jure donc
allez-y
merci merci beaucoup euh et et je je je
je vous rappelle également la la
nécessité de nous faire part le cas
échiant de vos éventuels lien d'intérêt
par rapport au
sujet dont nous allons débattre alors
quelques mots sur la Commission
elle-même elle a été constituée le 18
janvier
dernier sur le le thème donc de la
production de la consommation et du prix
d'électricité aux horizons 2035 et 2050
donc on va centrer nos travaux sur le
présent et l'avenir du système
électrique avec une question majeure
est-il en capacité de faire face à la
demande d'offrir au particulier à nos
entreprises une électricité à un prix
raisonnable quels sont ses et quelles
sont ses perspectives de
développement pour le déroulement de de
de l'audition nous avons souhaité
commencer par une table ronde
d'introduction qui nous permetta de
comprendre les bases euh de l'écosystème
électrique français quels sont les
acteurs en présence les acteurs
importants les bases de cet écosystème
et notamment en matière de rencontre de
l'offre et de la demande et de fixation
des prix alors il s'agit pour pour vous
mais pour nous aussi hein d'aider nos
nos concitoyens à appréhender le présent
et l'avenir de cet écosystème il s'agit
pas évidemment d'être exhaustif euh car
on va dérouler ensuite des une série
d'auditions sur des points plus
particuliers du du du du sujet mais on
voudrait donc donner une vue d'ensemble
la plus claire et objective possible de
la situation présente et en dégager les
grands enjeux si possible donc nous vous
proposons de dérouler cette audition en
quatre temps pour chacun d'entre vous 10
minutes maximum de présentation liminire
de votre
travail donc un exercice de de concision
euh un temps de questionsréponse en
particulier avec notre rapporteur euh de
lae et les membres de la commission
d'enquête qui le souhaiteront un temps
de réaction à l'égard des propos des
autres participants donc qui pourra
éventuellement être suivi d'une dernière
batterie de questions réponse de la part
de de notre commission d'enquête voilà
euh ce que nous vous proposons en terme
de modus opérandi et je vais donner la
parole à Monsieur perscebois et ensuite
on fera par ordre alphabétique monsieur
Percebois vous avez la la
parole bien merci monsieur le président
monsieur le Président Monsieur le rteur
mesdames
messieurs c'est un sujet complexe que de
comprendre aujourd'hui le prix de
l'électricité et son évolution alors je
vais dans un premier temps expliquer
depuis pourquoi depuis la libéralisation
qui a été introduite au début des années
2000 suite à la directive de 1996 on
peut considérer que cette
libéralisation est un échec relatif dans
la mesure où la concurrence n'a pas
permis d'obtenir tout les résultats que
certains escomptés alors je dirai un mot
ensuite des solutions que doquin ont
cherché à apporter et je terminerai
rapidement en disant quelle est la
solution qui a été retenue aujourd'hui
par par la France qui est en cours
d'ailleurs de de mise en œuvre alors le
premier point c'est qu'en effet on a
voulu faire avec cette libéralisation
une ouvert sur la concurrence de la
production de la fourniture évidemment
pas des monopoles naturels que sont les
réseaux de transport et distribution et
concernant la production on est allé
d'emblé vers un marché de gros qui peut
se comprendre mais qui je dirais imp
posé un C de difficultés parce que bah
l'électricité ne se stock pas et donc un
marché fondé sur des prix horaires ce
qu'on appelle le spot et bien ce marchél
entraîne une volatilité très forte de
l'électricité ça tient à la nature même
du produit puisque c'est un produit qui
se stock pas et donc on a une volatilité
qui fait que le prix de l'électricité à
certains moment est négatif à d'autres
moments peut s'envoler alors beaucoup
considèrent qu'il est anormal que le
prix de l'électricité soit calé sur à
certain moment le coût du gaz ce n'est
pas normal la logique d'un marché de
gros heure par heure c'est que le prix
soit calé sur le coût de fonctionnement
de la dernière centrale dont on a besoin
pour équilibrer le le réseau et en
général pas toujours la centrale
marginale la dernière centrale c'est une
centrale à gaz pendant longtemps quand
le prix des du gaz ou le prix du du du
charbon était relatif ement bas les prix
de gros étaient relat FAI pendant toute
la période 2010 2020 jusqu'en 2021 on a
eu des coûts marginaux qui étent
inférieur au coût moyen et donc le prix
du marché ne permettait pas de recouvrir
les coûts fixes des centrales on a
d'ailleurs fermé beaucoup de centrales a
commencé par des centrales à gaz ce qui
s'est passé c'est que depuis 2022 on a
le phénomène inverse c'est que le coût
marginal est aujourd'hui au-dessus du
coût moyen donc les prix se sont avolés
en 2022 mais c'est une année un peu un
peu parti parulre alors l'autre élément
qui pose problème c'est qu'on a cru à la
concurrence mais cette concurrence en
fait a subi beaucoup
d'exception on a fait des exceptions
parce que on a aidé les renouvelables en
leur mettant des prix garantis au départ
défini une tarif donc des prix d'achat
garanti ensuite on a instauré un système
de l'arène l'accès régulé à l'énergie
nucléaire historique sur la base de
l'idée que tous les consommateurs
français ayant participé au financement
du nucléaire historique il était
légitime qui continu en profiter même
s'ils ne sont plus clients d'EDF sauf
que la loi prévoyait au départ que le
prix de laarine devait être revalorisé
au fil du temps en tenant compte de
l'inflation et et des coûts supportés
par l'opérateur historique ce qui n'a
pas été le cas puisque la reine depuis
le premier janvier 2012 est toujours à
42 € le le megaw on a maintenu des terv
ce qui était logique pour protéger le
petit consommateur mais en introduisons
une disposition qui pose problème et qui
explique que beaucoup de Français
aujourd'hui ont du mal à comprendre pour
quoi la structure du prix qu'il paye le
tarif réglementé de vente ne coïcide pas
avec la structure du mix électrique on
introduit le grand principe de la
contestabilité la contestabilité ça veut
dire que le prix le TRV le prix donc
régulé réglementé dont bénéficie EDF
pour cette électricité doit être
contestable par les opérateurs
alternatifs ce qui veut dire que la
structure du TRV doit être la même que
la structure des des des alternatifes et
donc comme ils n'ont pas suffisamment de
de nucléaire il y a un principe
décrêtement lorsque la demande d'arène
est supérieure à l'offre qui est fixé
par la loi à 100 TWh et bien on
introduit un écrêtement et cet
écrêtement fait que la part de du prix
du marché est plus importante que la
part je dirais du de l'électricité
d'origine fossile dans dans le dans le
dans le le mix électrique français donc
on a aujourd'hui un système qui don un
sombre de difficultés alors faut pas
imputer toutes les difficultés au marché
par exemple si on regarde ce qui s'est
passé entre 2010 et 2021 l'augmentation
du prix de l'électricité a quand même
été importante elle a été de l'ordre de
80 82 % et quand on essaie de voir
qu'est-ce qui est à l'origine de cette
augmentation la première raison ce sont
les taxes 55 % d'augmentation est du aux
taxes pourquoi parce qu'on a aidé les
renouvelables la deuxième raison c'est
l'augmentation des péages c'estàdire des
tarifs d'accès au réseau la trème de
raison c'est le prix du marché 23 % mais
tout n'est pas la faute du marché on a
évidemment une part importante
du à l'augmentation des taxes alors
l'envolet des prix gros en 2022
s'explique essentiellement parce que on
a une conjonction de facteur
défavorable une électricité hydraulique
insuffisante surtout une disponibilité
du parc nucléaire plus faible que prévu
et puis bien sûr une augmentation
considérable du prix du gaz et encore
une fois la logique du marché sur la
base de ce qu'on appelle des enchères à
prix limite fait que et bien le prix du
marché est calé sur le coût de
fonctionnement de la dernière centrale
disponible et donc c'est la centrale à
gaz quand le prix du gaz est monté à 345
€ le MWh comme il faut à peu près 2 MWh
de gaz pour faire 1 MWh deélectricité le
prix de l'électricité est monté à 2 xis
345 plus le coût du CO2 c'est-à-dire à
peu près aux alentours de 750 € il y a
même eu des pointes au-delà de 750 € le
MWh donc c'est tout à fait logique pour
un économiste d'avoir observé cette
cette situation alors depuis les prix
sont revenus à un niveau plus normal ce
qui s'explique par le la chute du prix
du gaz et aujourd'hui les prix de gros
de l'électricité sont relativement
faibles il sont aux alentours de 80 100
ils sont un petit peu plus élevé
aujourd'hui mais c'est une volatilité
qui est tout à fait qui est tout à fait
acceptable alors il faut comprendre que
quand le consommateur pe son électricité
une part importante si en effet le coût
de fourniture aujourd'hui le
consommateur il paye au 1er février il
va payer à peu près 28 centimes d'euros
sur ces 28 centimes il y a 12,5 centimes
qui correspond au coup de fourniture il
y a 6,12 centimes qui correspond au
péage et il y a à peu près 7 centimes
qui correspondent aux taxes he y compris
la fameuse ticf alors quand on a voulu
je dirais euh prendre conscience que
cette situation posait problème parce
que cette augmentation très importante
des prix de l'électricité était
difficile à supporter par le
consommateur euh certains on dit c'est
la preuve que le marché fonctionne pas
doncun on répondu c'est pas vrai parce
que justement le fait que les prix est
est monter à ce niveau-là ça a permis
aux centrales à gaz de fonctionner et
d'une certaine façon on a évité le
blackout pour éviter le blackout on a
été obligé d'accepter des prix
extrêmement élevés alors face à ça
quelles sont les les réformes qui ont
été qui ont été proposé au fond je
dirais qu'il y a trois approches
possibles la première c'est ceux qui
disent bah écoutez ça prouve que le
système fonctionne pas il faut revenir à
l'ancien système c'est-à-dire au
monopole public donc ça c'est une
position je dirais qui a ses défenseurs
et qui a des arguments le retour
monopole public intégré paraît
aujourd'hui à la fois juridiquement
difficile et politiquement improbable la
deuxème solution c'est de dire il
faudrait faire une concurrence qui soit
un peu différente de celle qu'on a mis
en place c'estàdire au lieu de faire une
concurrence par le marché faire une
concurrence pour le marché c'est-à-dire
faire l'acheteur unique le gestionnaire
du réseau L serait des des des des
demandes à satisfaire donc il y aurait
des des des offreurs qui répondrait à
cette demande à ces enchères mais
simplement à ce moment-là les contrats
seraient des contrats de long terme
c'est-à-dire que le producteur aurait en
quelque sorte une concession pendant une
certaine durée et le prix serait calé
non pas sur le coût marginal mais sur le
coût moyen c'est-à-dire à la fois sur
les coûts variaable mais surtout sur les
coûts fixes le troisème système c'est en
fait le système qui va être adopté par
l'Union europé
et qui aujourd'hui est la solution
retenue c'est de dire bien gardons le
marché gardons le marché de gros mais
mettons des gardesfous c'est-à-dire en
fait bien mettons une barre un prix
plancher mettons un prix plafond un prix
plancher parce que si le prix tombe il
faut quand même que les opérateurs
puisse récupérer leur coût fixe et puis
un prix plafond parce qu'à ce moment-là
il faut protéger le le consommateur donc
le système qui est retenu dans ce cas-là
c'est ce qu'on appelle le système des
contrats pour différence alors on peut
avoir voir un prix plancher différent du
prix plafond ou un prix plancher égal au
prix plafond dans un cas on a des
contrats pour différence avec corridor
dans l'autre c'est des contrats pour
différence de type bilatéral et donc
l'idée c'est et bien si le prix s'envole
l'État en quelque sorte taxe récupère ce
qui est au-delà du du prix plafond et
donc peut redistribuer cela au au
consommateur final alors la solution
retenue ça c'est la solution proposée en
octobre novembre par par Bruxelles par
je dirais l'Europe la solution retenue
en France aujourd'hui semble être un peu
différente c'està- direire que la France
est beaucoup batue pour avoir des
contrats pour différence applicable au
nucléaire historique notamment et on
semble mettre en place alors c'est pas
encore complètement finalisé un système
où il y aurait simplement une sorte de
prix plafond c'est-à-dire un système de
double taxation l'état taxerait le
nucléaire aulà de 78 € à 50 % et puis
au-delà de 110 € à 90 %. il récupérit
cela et ce serait redistribué au
consommateur final alors ça pose un
certain nombre de de questions
évidemment parce que est-ce que les prix
vont s'envoler est-ce que les prix
risquent pas d'être tras parce qu'il y a
plus de prix plancher est-ce qu'il y a
pas un risque pour l'opérateur
historique que le prix gros tombe en
dessous d'un certain seuil alors on peut
toujours dire il y a une une solution de
rappel en quelque sorte parce que le
système en général est négocié pour 3
ans et au bout de 3 ans on peut revenir
au système des contrats pour différence
puisque de toute façon c'est accepté
mais enfin c'est une question qui mérite
d' posé ensuite l'État va prélever
au-delà d'un certain seuil j'ai dit les
deux systèmes 78 et 110 € qu'est-ce
qu'il va faire cette somme normalement
il redistribue au consommateur va-t-il
tout redistribuer ça c'est une question
qui est posée comment va-t-il le
redistribuer par l'intermédiaire des
fournisseurs les fournisseurs vont-ils
répercuter ça c'est une autre question
quand on voit la façon dont certains ont
répercuté la reine on peut s'inquiéter
donc voilà des questions qui méritent
d'être posées mais enfin pour l'instant
on peut pas faire de de procès
d'intention je voudrais Simp simplement
conclure en disant que de toute façon le
système fondé sur les coûts marginaux
peut pas être pérenne pour une raison
extrêmement simple c'est qu'on a deux
types de centrales on a des centrales
qui sont des centrales pour lesquelles
la part des coup fixes est très élevée
c'est le cas des renouvelable et celle
cas du nucléaire et on a des centrales
où c'est la part du coup variable qui
est très élevé ce sont les centrales qui
utilisent des énergies fossiles les
centrales à gaz les centrales à charbon
donc il est logique que quand la
majorité des
centrales est constitué par des
centrales à coût variable élevé le prix
soit calé sur le coût de fonctionnement
de ces centrales qui font l'équilibre
mais demain ces centrales à énergie
fossile vont disparaître par conséquent
on ne pourra plus avoir un prix calé sur
le coût marginal des centrales à fortes
proportion de coût fixe ça veut dire
qu'il faudra nécessairement un système
qui sera calé sur le coût moyen des
centrales à forte proportion de coût
fixe que ce soit les centrales
renouvelables éoliennes ou photovoltaïqu
ou ou ou les centrales nucléaires donc
de toute façon il faudra réfléchir à un
système qui soit pérenne sur le long
terme pour faciliter la transition
énergétique merci monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup monsieur
perscebois
euh je passer la parole à Monsieur de
Monsieur de de zobri pardon excusez-moi
monsieur de zobri vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les membres de la commission
merci beaucoup pour votre invitation à
participer à C estce excusez-moi alors
il faut qu'on se cale nous dans notre
fonctionnement aussi je salue les les
collègues qui nous ont qui nous ont
rejoint qui se présenteront peut-être en
en posant les les les questions ou je
les présente come POS je poser voilà je
je je vais on va plutôt poser les les
questions au niveau du rapporteur pour
le rapporteur après chaque intervention
excuse a été dit pardon par rapport à ce
qui a été dit précédemment mais merci
Monsieur perscebois pour pour cette
analyse globale euh c'est vrai que le
souci que l'on a et qu'à notre
commission d'enquête que que la France a
c'est effectivement d'avoir des des prix
de l'électricité qui soient le le moins
volatile possible et que
le le prix du marché sur la base d'un
d'un coût marginal qu'on comprend bien
dans le fonctionnement du marché fait
que aujourd'hui on a quand même du mal à
anticiper et quand on a du mal à
anticiper on a du mal à réagir aussi
derrière que ça soit pour les
particuliers comme pour les entreprises
donc c'est pas une solution euh qui nous
paraît très très viable quoi qui me
paraît très viable en tout cas
euh je je je suis plutôt moi plutôt
partisan d'essayer de se rapprocher du
coup moyen de production sachant qu'on a
effectivement des moyens de production
en France qui ont des coûts fixes
importants et assez peu de coûts variabl
et ça paraît être plutôt la logique
qu'il faudrait suivre est-ce que dans
ces cas-là vous pensez qu'il faudrait
avoir quand même des moyens euh
pilotable entre guillemets de de pour
assurer les pointes par rapport à à
cette la production par par nos moyens
de production à coût fixe important ou
euh voilà est-ce qu'il faut est-ce qu'il
faut importer quand on a des
pointes tout à l'heure j'ai dit on
distingue les central à forte proportion
de coût fixe et les centrales à forte
proportion de coût variable il y a une
autre distinction qui vient sur super
posé c'est les centrales pilotables et
les centrales non pilotables les
renouvelables sont des centrales non
pilotables elles répondent pas
nécessairement à la demande hein ça
dépend de contrainte extérieure alors
euh il est certain qu'aujourd'hui pour
passer la pointe on on est obligé de
garder soit des des des des centrales à
gaz parce qu'on va pas construire une
centrale nucléaire pour la faire
fonctionner quelques heures de pointe
soit on importe de l'électricité au fond
si on n'ortait pas l'électricité
d'Allemagne aux hord de PO il faudrait
construire davantage de centrale à gaz
en France c'est un peu le l'arbitre
l'arbitrage à à effectuer ou alors faire
baisser la demande aux h de pointe c'est
un autre moyen et qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous pensez qu'il faudrait
faire alors je pense je pense qu'à
l'heure actuelle moi je suis favorable à
un système qui permettrait de caler le
prix sur le coût moyen alors je j'ai dit
tout à l'heure que avec ce système des
contrats pour différence c'est un peu
l'objectif d'éviter la volatilité il y a
un autre système dont j'ai pas parlé
mais qui est très important c'est que
parallèlement au contrat pour différence
la Commission européenne a accepté qu'on
mette en place des pipiers c'est-à-dire
des contrats à long terme entre les
producteurs et les fournisseurs les
producteurs et les consommateurs alors
ça c'est le moyen en effet je dirais
d'avoir une bonne partie d'électricité
vendue hors marché parce qu'à ce
moment-là les contrats pipier ce sont
des contrats de droit privé le CFD c'est
un contrat de droit public c'est l'État
qui intervient dans les PIP c'est le le
producteur qui négocie avec le
fournisseur qui négocie avec qui négocie
avec le le client alors bien évidemment
si on a une architecture fondée à la
fois sur des CFD et sur des PP on peut
je dirais stabiliser relativement les
prix de
l'électricité la question c'est est-ce
qu'on maintient un marché la réponse est
oui de toute façon il faudra un marché
je dirais pour la pointe c'est pas
complètement irréaliste d'avoir un
marché pour la pointe un marché aussi
spot pour les échanges internationaux
faut pas oublier que dans le passé quand
on regarde la tarification EDF
tarification ej pddf effacement j de
pointe vous aviez des prix aux heur de
pointe qui étaient extrêmement élevés
hein et donc c'est une façon de dire au
consommateurs si vous souscrivez ce
tarif faites attention ça va vous coûter
très cher donc je pense si vous voulez
qu'il faut que l'essentiel de
l'électricité soit vendu à un prix qui
est proche du coupmyen soit dans le
cadre de système de CFD qui permettent
de stabiliser les prix soit en y
assoutant des pipiers évidemment la
Commission européenne va être vigilante
parce que les pipiier c'est un contrat
entre le producteur et le consommateur
ou le fournisseur et donc quand vous
avez un opérateur historique qui a un
poids très important la Commission va
regarder de près bon ça d'autre part il
faut laisser un peu de souplesse donc
c'est pas incompatible avec le maintien
d'un marché de gros je dirais pour je
vous dire encore une fois les échanges
extérieurs ou simplement la pointe ça
n'a rien d'exceptionnel l'objectif c'est
d'éviter qu'on ait des systèmes où euh à
certains moment tout le monde soit calé
sur le coût marginal exceptionnellement
élevé comme ça était le cas en 2022 mais
2022 est quand même une année un peu
exceptionnelle sil y a d'autres
questions est-ce que mes collègues
souhaitent intervenir Daniel Daniel
salement merci oui votre conclusion est
assez intéressante puisquon a souvent
tendance à jeter le bébé avec l'eau du
bain pour vous 2022 était une année très
particulière on l'a vu donc avec cette
problématique de de prix du gaz et cette
problématique du parc nucléaire qui
n'était pas disp disponible quels sont
pour vous les les probabilités que cela
se reproduise et si cette probabilité
est très faible faut-il continuer à
garder le système
actuel de toute façon le système actuel
il va être amendé puisqu'on a décidé de
mettre en place un système de double
taxation tout en privilégiant à côté des
des contrats directs entre les
producteurs les fournisseurs et les
clients je crois que de ce point de vue
c'est plutôt une bonne chose simplement
je dirais le diable est dans les détails
il faut regarder la mise en œuvre de ce
système parce que concrètement ça veut
dire
que quel va être le prix de
l'électricité en 2026 27 28 si on
regarde parce qu'il y a un marché à
terme aussi évidemment j'ai pas le temps
d'en parler mais il y a des
anticipations sur les prochaines années
les anticipations 2027- 2028 les prix
sont plutôt bas on est entre 60 et 70 €
le mgawh vous me direz qu'en 2023 les
anticipations pour 2024 2025 elles était
à 400 € le mgawh donc les anticipations
sont souvent tributaires de ce qu'on
observe à l'instant au moment où on les
fait donc il faut être extrêmement
prudent dans l'interprétation mais on
peut avoir deux risques le premier c'est
que les prix chutent on a connu dans le
passé des prix encore une fois trop bas
y compris des prix négatifs pendant pas
mal de temps n'oubliez pas qu'en 2016-
2017 le prix de la le prix du marché de
gros était inférieur au niveau de
l'arine bon alors aujourd'hui si vous
voulez on a on a on a plus
le système mis en place est un système
très complexe qui fait que même la reen
si vous voulez à 42 € aujourd'hui alors
ça c'est une difficulté pour permettre
la transition il faudrait que le niveau
de l'arine soit augmenté normalement
c'était prévu dans la loi n on oublie
souvent la commission charmsor l'avait
proposé la loi l'a entériné simplement
le décret d'application est jamais sorti
donc il était bien prévu
que on tient compte de l'inflation si
vous tenez compte de l'inflation entre
2012 et 2022 vous êtes à entre 15 et 20
1 % à cela sajoute des coûts qui ont été
supportés par EDF pour entretenir le
parc historique donc il faudrait que la
reine soit revalorisée ce qui me
surprend un peu c'est que on n pas
réussi par la loi à la revaloriser entre
2024 et 2026 enfin puce que la reen va
s'arrêter le 31 décembre 2025
apparemment on considère qu'elle va
rester le niveau de laarine va rester à
42 € jusque décembre 2020 25 est-ce
qu'il y aurait pas moyen de faire une
transition
pour passer progressivement de 42 à à à
60 ou 70 la Commission de régulation a
dit que le coût du nucléaire historique
c'était aux alentours de 60 € le mgawh
etedf a dit non c'est pas 60 c'est
plutôt 75 bon il faut dire qu'ils
prennent pas les mêmes hypothèses donc
c'est logique ils aboutissent pas au
même résultat mais c'est sûrement pas 42
donc là il y a certainement peut-être un
effort à faire à ce niveau je je
vous c'est juste une une question
monsieur monsieur Percebois dans les
PPI est-ce qu'il y a une ce sont des
contrats long terme est-ce qu'il y a une
prise en compte des investissements et
du financement des investissements à
réaliser au niveau du parc oui monsieur
le Président il y a deux types de PIP il
peut y avoir des PIP en mgaw en énergie
à ce moment-là c'est des PIP où le
fournisseur ou le gros consommateur on
va prendre un client
industriel achète je dirais pendant une
certaine période sur la base d'un accord
avec le producteur mais en euro par
mgawh il paye mais il a la garantie
qu'il a ce prix il y a d'autres PIP en
puissance cette fois c'est plus en mgaw
c'est en mégaw c'està-dire à ce
moment-là que le gros industriel ou le
fournisseur ça peut être par exemple un
fournisseur alternatif comme Total qui a
dit qui pouvit être intéressé ou un très
gros
électrointensif passe un contrat en
disant je suis prêt à financer une parti
d'un réacteur et en contrepartie et bien
j'aurai des droits de tirage sur la
production alors cette fois il prend un
risque parce qu'il participe avec
l'opérateur avec le producteur au risque
c'estàd que si la centrale fonctionne
pas bien il en supporte les conséquences
mais le système est pas nouveau il y a
très longtemps que ça existe en Finlande
c'est le système mancala qu'on mis en
place les les finlandais c'estàd c'est
des coopératives de gros industriels qui
participent au financement de barrages
évidemment de l'pr finlandais c'est
comme ça qu'en parti il est financé donc
comme EDF a du mal à trouver des
financements on peut en effet considérer
que c PIP en puissance sont un élément
important du du financement une réponse
au problème du
financement je vais laisser
les Madame C Denise simplement une
question
sur sur l'appel à la dernière centrale
qui contrôle est-ce qu'on a un
gendarme qui contrôle l'appel de à la
dernière centrale ou pas oui c'est c'est
RTE qui est chargé et bien de de régler
l'ensemble des des offres et et des
demandes donc il y a un équilibre qui
est fait en temps réel le le seul rôle
du gendarme c'est de vérifier que il y a
pas de comportement de rétention de
capacité c'estàdire qu' est pas un
opérateur qui décide de pas non mais sur
le prix ben le prix le prix c'est en
fonction du prix annoncé par le
producteur d'une centrale à gaz si le
prix du gaz est à 345 € le MWh lui il
dit moi je fournit pas ma centrale à
moins de 750 donc dans les offres heure
par heure la veille pour le lendemain
c'est le marché spot des la veille pour
le lendemain il annonce 750 ou 800 et à
ce moment-là si le si on a besoin de lui
si on a besoin de lui le prix se cale
sur
victorurel merci merci merci monsieur le
Président si je comprends bien d'ici
2025 avec les réformes annoncé le marché
de l'électricité va être partiellement
ou fondamentalement
modifié et les propositions que vous
faites de dire remplacer le prix Ader un
coout marginal serait peut-être plus
intelligent et plus pertinent en faisant
un prix adosser au cou moyen de
production prière chose l'Europe propose
que dans le temps le marché à court
terme et notamment le spot soit adossé à
des contrats à long terme comment ça va
fonctionner parce que si on prend
certains pays parce qu'on un marché
unifié on a des zones dans lesquelles
lorsqu'on a des pénurie interne on peut
importer avec des conditions
transfrontalières comment ça va
fonctionner lorsque l'Allemagne a un
coup moyen de production beaucoup plus
élevé comment ça ça le marché unique de
l'électricité va-t-il fonctionner avec
un coup
moyen de production je parle pas des des
pointes qui ont été gérées entre 80 et
100 terw chaque année ça a été euh géré
comment ça va fonctionner avec un cout
moyen avec la dispersion des couts dans
les centrales notamment euh euh un gaz
et je je parle pas de ligite de charbon
et et d'autres centrales énergie
fossile je précise déjà que la réforme
ne s'appliquera qu'au 1er janvier 2026
donc cette réforme elle ne change rien
en 2024 pour le moment elle ne change
rien même en principe à 2025 donc c'est
seulement à partir de 2026
alors maintenant il y a déjà en effet
des coûts très différents d'un pays à
l'autre il y a les interconnexions alors
euh je dirais chacun en quelque sorte
fait son son système et c'est c'est par
le biais des des interconnexions qu'on
voit si les marchés sont couplés ou si
les marchés sont séparés c'estàd que
quand les coûts les prix sont différents
d'un pays à l'autre on dit que les
marchés sont séparés hein surtout s'il y
a des des contraintes aux frontières
mais on peut parfaitement avoir des des
des coûts différents d'ailleurs c'est le
principe des vases communiquants les
coûts étaient différents d'un pays à
l'autre c'est pour ça qu'on a fait le
marché la France au départ a dit mais
nous on a un avantage on a des coûts
plus bas que les autres donc on va
exporter ce qui le cas d'ailleurs parce
qu'en régime de croisière la France
exportait 84 ou 85 TWh on en
impimportait 47 et une finé on avait 40
à 45 euh tawh d'excédent sauf en 2022 où
on a été déficitaire 16,5 je crois
terraw mais c'est exceptionnel cette
année de nouveau EDF est redevenu
excédentaire enfin la France c'est
redevenu prctement exportatrice net
n'oublions pas que ces exportations
nettes rapportent de l'ordre de 2
milliards au moins par an à la balance
commerciale française sauf en 2022 où ça
nous a coûté 7 milliards mais c'tait une
situation
exceptionnelle
pardon on on va je vais donner la parole
à Monsieur de zobri hein d'abord si si
vous permettez juste une précision pour
pour pour la Commission on reviendra sur
la le poste arè la réforme de de l'arè
spécifique ement à l'occasion d'un d'une
audition vous avez la parole monsieur de
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
pour faire le lien avec avec ce que ce
que vient de dire le professeur
perscebois ce qui est intéressant c'est
aussi de bien comprendre comment on est
arriver à se focaliser sur le marché de
gros de court terme parce que finalement
c'est pas juste l'ouverture à la
concurrence qui a conduit à cette
émergence du marché de gros de court
terme et donc c'est finalement la la la
la doctrine de la Commission européenne
qui a conduit à focaliser la tenenstion
sur le marché de gros de court terme et
qui aujourd'hui euh revient un peu sur
cette position dans le cadre de euh du
projet de règlement sur la réforme du
Market design alors sur le sur
finalement la raison pour laquelle on
s'est concentré sur le marché de gros et
le marché de gros de court terme est en
partie liée à la maturité des marchés de
l'électricité lorsqu'on a ouvert les
marchés à la concurrence à l'amont
c'est-à-dire au niveau de la production
quand on a ouvert à la concurrence dans
les années 2000 le parc de production
était presque surcapacitaire c'était le
cas en France et c'était aussi à peu
près le cas partout en Europe ce qui
veut dire que quand on a ouvert à la
concurrence les capacités de production
nécessaires étaient déjà là et en grande
partie amorti à l'aval c'est-à-dire du
côté de la commission euh de la
consommation pardon euh les
consommateurs la la consommation est
restée relativement stable pendant les
20 premières années de l'ouverture à la
concurrence ce qui veut dire que quand
on ouvre à la concurrence il y a déjà
tous les moyens de production qui
existent dont on a besoin et les
consommateurs ont déjà tous un contrat
avec un fournisseur donc la Commission
se dit bah quand on ouvre à la
concurrence on ne pourra pas avoir
l'émergence d'une concurrence avec des
acteurs intégrés à mon aval comme les
acteurs qu'on connaît comme les acteurs
historiques
EDF est un acteur intégré à mon aval
c'est-à-dire qu'il a développé ses
moyens de production et il vend en
grande partie sa production donc la
Commission européenne dit bah finalement
les seuls le le seul moyen pour que la
concurrence se développe c'est que des
commercialisateurs purs des fournisseurs
qui ne sont pas intégrés à mon aval
puissent arriver sur le marché et pour
que ces fournisseurs arrivent sur le
marché il faut qu'il y ait un marché de
gros suffisamment liquide pour qu'il
puisse acheter leur électricité et donc
à partir du moment où la Commission
européenne fait ce constat elle
considère que sa priorité c'est
d'assurer la liquidité des marchés de
gros et la liquidité des marchés de gros
de court terme notamment pour permettre
une meilleure pénétration des moyens de
production renouvelablebl et elle
commence à avoir des une approche même
négative à l'égard à la fois des
contrats long terme du côté amont
c'est-à-dire entre des producteurs et
des fournisseurs parce qu'elle considère
que ça vient assécher la liquidité des
marchés de gros et elle remet en cause
aussi l'intégré l'intégration amont aval
d'un certain nombre d'acteurs et
notamment de l'acteur historique
français et le projet Hercule c'était
finalement le démantelllement la
désoptimisation de l'amont et de l'aval
pour un opérateur qui avec l'idée de
d'approvisionner le marché de gros
c'est-à-dire dans l'idée de la
commission il fallait que les
producteurs vendent sur un marché de
gros les fournisseur s'approvisionne sur
ce marché de gros et plus ce marché de
gros est liquide et plus finalement la
concurrence va bien fonctionner et elle
est allée dans sa logique elle a
poursuivi en s'assurant comme la la
question que vous posiez c'est-à-dire
qui finalement va s'assurer quelle va
être cette dernière centrale et comment
on va s'assurer que il y a un juste prix
il y a une réglementation qui s'appelle
remit qui est en révision avec à côté du
du Règlement sur le Market design qui
interdit aux acteur de faire de la
manipulation de marché notamment de la
rétention de capacité et qui oblige tout
producteur à offrir sa production à son
coût marginal de production s'il le fait
pas il faut qu'il justifie de pourquoi
il ne le fait pas euh alors le problème
c'est que euh ce ce cette cette approche
de la commission elle n'a pas permis
d'atteindre les objectifs qu'on attend
du système électrique il y a trois
objectifs principaux il y a la sécurité
d'approvisionnement et le marché de gros
de court terme n'a pas permis d'envoyer
les bons signaux pour que les capacités
nécessaires pour assurer une sécurité
d'approvisionnement et donc les
États-membres ont mis en place des
mécanismes de capacité comme la France
par exemple le marché de gros de court
terme n'a pas permis non plus d'envoyer
les bons signaux pour servir l'objectif
de durabilité c'est-à-dire de
décarbonation du mix et c'est pour ça
que on a dû mettre en place des
dispositif de soutien pour permettre aux
renouvelables d'arriver et enfin le
marché de gr de court terme n'a pas
protégé le consommateur contre la
volatilité des prix et on l'a vu de
manière très sensible depuis la crise
sur les marchés de gros et donc le
constat c'est que B finalement ce marché
de gros et ce fonctionnement ne pourra
pas être la solution à la fois à la
crise climatique c'est-à-dire que on ne
peut pas espérer que le marché de gros
envoie les bons signaux pour développer
les capacités de production décarboné et
là on entre finalement dans un autre
dans une autre priorité qui va être
celle de la décarbonation avec des
investissements massif à l'amont on voit
les perspectives d' RTE sur la
croissance de la demande d'électricité
qui est vertigineuse c'est-à-dire qu'on
passe de 470 TWh par exemple en France
sur les 20 dernières années à 550 600
voir 700 TWh ce qui veut dire que la
maturité des marchés qu'on a connu
pendant 20 ans mais finalement on ne la
retrouve pas aujourd'hui alors qu'est-ce
que ça crée ça va créer un espace
pour des nouveaux investissements qui
seront portés en partie par l'opérateur
historique et en partie par d'autres
acteurs et à certains égards la
décarbonation va être au marché de
l'électricité ce que la numérisation a
été au marché des télécom si on avait
ouvert la à la concurrence les marchés
des télécom à un moment où il y avait
pas eu la numérisation on aurait eu
probablement les mêmes difficultés
que dans l'électricité et aujourd'hui on
se rend compte que si la concurrence a
été poussive finalement pendant 20 ans
qu'est-ce qu'on pouvait espérer de la
concurrence finalement une fois que on
dit que les fournisseurs sont des des
commercialisateurs et donc qu'ils ne
font que revendre ce que d'autres ont
produit on ne peut espérer de la
concurrence finalement que de gagner une
petite marge sur les coûts de
commercialisation parce que tout le
reste c'est la même chose pour tout le
monde les les coûts de réseau le
professeur perscebois a bien dit c'est
les mêmes pour tout le monde il y a 70 %
de l'électricité qui est acheté à
l'arine ou en tout cas un prix qui est
le même pour tout le monde et donc
finalement la concurrence ne s'exerçait
que sur une une frange extrêmement
réduite deuxème deuxème limite qu'il va
falloir combler ce sont c'est de lutter
contre la volatilité des prix sur les
marchés de gros et là la Commission
européenne dans son projet de règlement
elle
reconnaît
explicitement que bah finalement
peut-être qu'elle s'est trompée en
donnant une priorité au marché de gros
de court terme et que il faut prévoir
aujourd'hui de réintroduire des contrats
de long terme dans le système et ce sont
à la fois les PIP et à la fois les CFD
dont on parlait donc ça c'est le premier
point qui est à mon avis majeur sur les
le le futur du système électrique c'est
que on passe d'un monde où le marché
était très mature était très fermé à un
monde où il va falloir investir
massivement il va falloir trouver les
moyens qui permettent d'investir et de
sécuriser les investissements des
opérateurs le deuxième grand changement
c'est l'appréhension que les
consommateurs se font de l'électricité
les entreprises les collectivités et
aujourd'hui les résidentiels finalement
non plus ne ne se satisfont plus juste
d'un contrat fourniture classique ils
réfléchissent à valoriser leur potentiel
de production par exemple en
autoconsommation ils veulent
s'approvisionner en partie à travers des
pipiers renouvelables pour des raisons
RSE ou autres et finalement on voit que
laprovisionnement en électricité
aujourd'hui va être une addition de
briques qui vont être qui vont répondre
à des produits différents et tous ces
produits ça va être aussi la
valorisation de la flexibilité de la
demande hein monsieur perscebois l' très
bien dit avec la nécessité de prévoir de
développer à la fois l'effacement mais
de manière générale le stockage et la
flexibilité de la demande il va falloir
que le consommateur réponde aussi à des
signaux et ça ce sera fait par
finalement l'arrivée sur le marché de
nouveaux produits de nouveaux de de de
nouveaux produits proposés par des
fournisseurs mais aussi par d'autres
acteurs on parle de l'écosystème du
système électrique euh il y a bien sur
les fournisseurs les producteurs comme
on les a toujours connus mais
aujourd'hui on est obligé de
réinterroger les anciennes catégories
dans le monde d'avant on parlait du
marché de gros et du marché de détail
avec les producteurs les fournisseurs et
puis les consommateurs aujourd'hui par
exemple un pipier qu'évoquait le
professeur perscebois c'est entre un
producteur et un consommateur alors où
est-ce qu'on le classe est-ce qu'on le
classe dans le marché de gros ben non
est-ce qu'on le classe dans le marché de
détail non c'est pas un cont contrat de
fourniture c'est autre chose
l'effacement de consommation c'est la
possibilité pour les consommateurs de
valoriser leur profil de consommation
sur les marchés de gros et donc on est
obligé de repenser la délimitation des
marchés tel qu'on la connaît depuis
depuis l'ouverture à la concurrence le
dernier point sur lequel je
souhaiterais appeler votre attention
c'est la dimension européenne alors la
dimension européenne dans la
construction européenne la la la la
question énergétique dans la
construction européenne elle a été
majeure il y a deux traités sur les
trois qui sont centrés sur l'énergie le
le traité CK et le traité Euratom traité
Euratom que pour lequel la Cour de
justice est venue rappeler en 2020 qu'il
avait la même valeur que les autres
traités européens et qu'il disait
finalement que collectivement la
communauté de l'Atom avait pour objet de
développer le nucléaire et ça elle le
dit en 2020 donc à à l'échelle
européenne l'Europe a toujours joué un
rôle central la question aujourd'hui
c'est celle des risques et des tensions
on voit des tensions très fortes entre
les États sur la question nucléaire hein
on connaît l'alliance du renouvelable et
l'alliance du nucléaire on a vu toutes
les difficultés de la France à faire
entrer le nucléaire dans la taxonomie ce
qui est très curieux puisque c'est
aujourd'hui inscrit dans les traités
c'est-à-dire que dans les traités on
doit qui favoriser le le le
développement du nucléaire d'une
certaine manière et puis le le le
dernier élément c'est que l'énergie
aujourd'hui est source de tension entre
les États on le voit à travers un
certain nombre d'affaire l'affaire incle
point où l'Autriche et le Luxembourg
attaquent des décisions d'aide d'État
favorbl pour le développement de
capacité nucléaire en en Grande-Bretagne
on le voit avec l'affaire Opal où là
c'est la la l'Allemagne la Pologne qui
attaque l'Allemagne parce que il réforme
une décision sur l'approvisionnement en
gaz et finalement la question qu'on peut
se poser c'est aujourd'hui en terme
d'intégration est-ce qu'il faut plus
d'intégration européenne ou moins
d'intégration européenne on a
l'impression qu'avec les crises qu'on a
traversé il y a plutôt un retour au
niveau des États mais un retour au
niveau des États sans coordination ça
risque d'exacerber les tensions entre
les États-membres puisque si chaque
état-membre développe sa sa propre
stratégie énergétique ça va
nécessairement avoir des effets pervers
ou des effets des externalités sur les
sur les sur les États voisins et ça
risque de créer des tensions encore plus
fortes donc là on est à un moment un peu
clé où finalement tout est remis sur la
table à la fois au niveau européen avec
ce projet de texte de la Commission
européenne où elle dit bah finalement
tout est rebattu toutes les cartes sont
rebattues à la fois au niveau interne
avec la fin de l'arène et la la la
nécessité de réinventer un modèle voilà
et donc c'est un moment un peu clé pour
intervenir sur ce sujet merci monsieur
le Président merci à vous monsieur de de
zobri question monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le Président
effectivement si c'est un moment clé
c'est pour ça qu'on a constitué cette
commission d'enquête pour essayer d'y
voir clair et et en vous écoutant moi je
me posais la question effectivement le
marché le marché européen finalement
est-ce que c'est une bonne ou une
mauvaise chose je me pose la question
parce que vous y voyez quand même pas
pas mal de d'inconvénients en tout cas
vous avez décrit un certain nom
d'inconvénients est-ce que vous avez
connaissance de d'études ou
d'évaluations qui ont été faites sur les
avantages et les inconvénients que qu'on
a vécu parce que finalement on a
l'impression qu'avant 2000 cétait
relativement simple et que c'est assz
complexifié avec beaucoup d'intervenants
avec effectivement l'émergence aussi des
énergies renouvelables un certain nombre
de choses qui ont qui ont compliqué le
fonctionnement du marché et la
compréhension par par le citoyen de ce
marché euh donc que voilà ma première
question c'est de savoir est-ce que il y
a une déjà une évaluation à votre avis
ou est-ce que et est-ce que si on
retourne vers des des positions un peu
plus nationales entre guillemets même si
même s'il y a une coopération européenne
on peut penser qu'il peut y avoir aussi
peut-être un retour vers des politiques
plus nationales est-ce que dans ces
cas-là qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
renforcement des interconnexions parce
qu'on nous dit qu'il y a il y a des
investissements colossaux à réaliser en
terme de d'interconnexion européenne et
de réseau en France aussi hein mais on y
viendra aussi dans dans dans nos dans
différentes auditions mais moi j'ai
entendu parler de 500 milliards au
niveau 400 ou 500 milliards au niveau
européen ce qui veut dire que la la
facture de la France serait entre 50 70
milliards quelque chose comme ça donc
est-ce que ça vaut le coup de faire de
dépenser ces50 ou 70
milliards vous avez la alors sur
sur l'échelle européenne est-ce que le
marché européen est une bonne chose ou
pas ce qui est certain c'est que à
l'échelle de la France le l'Europe a
toujours été intégré dans les décisions
le professeur perscebois rappelé tout à
l'heure que le parc nucléaire a toujours
exporté entre 50 et 6 70 tawh par an
et quand Marcel boîux avait été
auditionné à l'Assemblée nationale en
2014 il disait que ça ça résultait d'un
contrat entre EDF et l'État français EDF
devait exporter 70 TWh pour faire
rentrer pour améliorer la balance
commerciale donc dès la la la
configuration du parc nucléaire la
dimension européenne avait été intégrée
alors après il y avait pas les marchés
européens l'Europe des réseaux est
plutôt un succès et je crois que ça
c'est ça fait consensus c'est-à-dire que
aujourd'hui le fait que on ait une
plaque européenne à l'échelle européenne
qui soit qui permette à l'électricité de
transiter sécurise l'ensemble des des
des acteurs et c'est c'est perçu comme
une bonne chose quand on on a eu la
crise ukrainienne on a vu à quel point
le réseau européen était en capacité de
de de d'aider les réseaux qui avaient et
donc c'est la même chose si nous demain
on avait un problème sur sur des des des
actifs de production comme ça a été le
cas quand on a connu la le phénomène de
corrosion sous contrainte les
interconnexions et donc le reste du
réseau européen a joué son rôle par
ailleurs le système d'interconnexion et
le couplage des marchés qui permet de de
de faire transiter l'électricité
toujours du pays le moins cher vers le
pays le plus cher assure qu'à chaque
instant finalement on a au niveau du mix
européen le prix le plus compétitif
possible alors certes avec des rentes de
congestion qui peuvent être importantes
parce que il n'y a pas assez de moyens
d'interconnexion et là c'est le
renforcement des capacités
d'interconnexion que vous évoquiez
aujourd'hui la France fait partie des
pays les plus interconnecté au niveau
européen mais il y a encore beaucoup de
projets en cours sur un certain nombre
de frontières et ça c'est plutôt une
bonne chose après sur votre question de
est-ce qu'il existe des bilans sur le
les les les Bénéfic euh la commission
parle de 34 milliards d'euros par an moi
je je je je suis pas compétent pour
juger ou apprécier ce chiffre ce qui est
certain c'est que aujourd'hui on
n'imagine pas euh on Nimagine pas se
couper des des autres réseaux européens
je pense que le coût serait serait
beaucoup trop important pour le
consommateur pour le consommateur
français ce qui ne veut pas dire que ce
marché de gros de court terme et le
design qui a été celui qui a été
privilégié par la Commission européenne
pendant 20 ans reste adapté au défis que
auquel doit faire face le système
électrique s'il y a pas j'aurais une
question monsieur de zobri par rapport à
à votre développement quand vous
avez insister sur l'enjeu de la de la
décarbonation dans ce dans cet
écosystème quid de la du niveau du prix
de carbone dans ce dans ce modèle et
dans ce dans ce modèle de de marché et
par rapport au aux aux évolutions qui
sont qui sont envisagé notamment au
niveau du du du Market
design alors les les liens aujourd'hui
entre les marchés de l'énergie et les
marchés du carbone sont de plus en plus
de plus en plus interdépendant d'une
certaine manière sur la l'électricité en
tant que tel le prix du carbone doit
être un élément qui favorise la
décarbonation puisque que en en taxant
ou en tout cas en faisant payer
davantage les producteurs d'électricité
à partir de moyens carboné on va inciter
et permettre le développement de moyens
de production décarboné ensuite il y a
la question de la décarbonation de
l'industrie et là la question de la
décarbonation de l'industrie elle se
fait notamment par la croissance des
moyens de production d'électricité
décarbonée le nucléaire et le
renouvelable et elle se fait aussi par
euh des à la fois une stabilité des prix
qui permettent aux industriels de faire
les investissements dans des moyens de
production décarbonés on parlait des CFD
tout à l'heure les contrats pour
différence on a les contrats carbone
pour différence qui arrivent
c'est-à-dire des contrats qui
fonctionnent un petit peu comme les
contrats pour différence avec pour
objectif de permettre la décarbonation
la plus rapide possible au moindre coût
pour les autorités publiques je sais pas
si je je réponds à votre question ma ma
question je était par rapport au niveau
à la prise en compte du prix du carbone
alors dans le système alors l'impression
que j'ai mais elle est peut-être
elle est peut-être pas bonne c'est que
c'est que aujourd'hui on est à des
niveaux de prix du carbone pas
suffisamment haut pour donner les bons
signes en matière de décarbonation mais
je me trompe peut-être c'est voilà je
alors et et comment cet élément là il il
est pris au niveau du du du en compte
compte par les acteurs et et et dans le
marché alors sur le marché de gros de
court terme les les coûts marginaux
intègrent le coût du carbone
c'est-à-dire que quand on a la centrale
marginale qui est une qui est une
centrale qui utilise des énergies
fossiles elle doit intégrer dans son
prix le coût du carbone donc plus on va
faire appel à des moyens carbonés et
plus le prix du carbone va être élevé et
plus le consommateur va payer cher son
en électricité donc ça c'est ça c'est un
premier point euh le
le le le deuxième point c'est que bah
finalement le système ets tel qu'il est
si on considère qu'aujourd'hui le prix
du carbone n'est pas suffisamment élevé
il faut regarder la manière dont le prix
carb pr ets c'est le marché du carbone
organisé périmètre européen de l'Union
euréne ça exactement le marché du
carbone qui est en cours de révision
dans le cadre du paquet fit for 55
c'est-à-dire dans pour
aligner l'Union européenne sur
l'objectif de décarbonation de 55 % en
2030 par rapport aux émissions de 1990
la Commission européenne a publié un
paquet le paquet fit for 55 qui prévoit
le une réforme ou en tout cas d'amender
le système de quotas de carbone
notamment pour arrêter les quôtas
gratuits pour mettre en place le fameux
CBA am dont on parle qui permet de
réintégrer le prix du carbone au aux aux
importations de produits pour lesquels
la production dans leurs états d'origine
n'aurait pas été n'aurait pas donné lieu
à un paiement du prix du
carbone merci Monsieur de zaubri s'il y
a pas de de question je
je si vas-y très rapidement monsieur le
Président merci pour ce ça bien jeuné
pardon pour ces informations euh vous
l'avez déjà un peu dit mais est-ce que
vous pourriez approfondir
euh vous semblez estimer que l'ouverture
à la concurrence finalement a eu des
effets très limités puisque ça s'est
joué sur les commercialisateurs pas sur
les producteurs et donc au moment où ça
a été mis en place quels étaient les
bénéfices attendus est-ce qu'on espérait
beaucoup plus dans quel domaine est-ce
que finalement on espérait peu on a eu
peu et donc c'est assez cohérent ou
est-ce qu'il y a des paril qui avaient
été fait à l'époque qui n'ont pas été
remplis alors dans dans l'audition de
Marcel boitou que je citais tout à
l'heure euh il il revient sur ce sujet
en disant mais finalement
euh peut-être que c'était pas une bonne
idée d'ouvrir à la concurrence à ce
moment-là et donc il y a probablement
une position dogmatique aussi de la
Commission européenne à un moment de de
de de l'Union européenne sur bah voilà
le marché c'est bien donc on va
appliquer dans l'électricité ce qu'on a
appliqué aux autres par ailleurs on
restait sur l'exemple des télécom qui
avaient plutôt très bien fonctionné et
les télécoms ont très bien fonctionné
aussi parce que il y a eu cette
numérisation la numérisation de de
l'économie qui a été concomitante à
l'ouverture à la concurrence
et c'est on s'est vite rendu compte que
après l'ouverture à la concurrence euh
au niveau européen on n'a pas forcément
eu tous les bénéfices qu'on pouvait
attendre donc je sais pas au niveau de
la Commission européenne la part du
politique et la part de croyance dans
que le miracle des télécom allait se se
se se renouveler dans le secteur de
l'énergie en tout cas en 2007 quand elle
a ouvert une enquête sectorielle
c'est-à-dire 5 ans après le le les
premières
libéralisations en 2005 elle ouvre une
enquête sectorielle pour compr comendre
ce qui se passe sur ces marchés qui sont
quand même très complexes et pour
lesquels elle a pris le temps de
s'acculturer elle a publier son rapport
en 2007 où elle comprend toutes les
difficultés à à faire vivre une
concurrence sur un
marché beaucoup trop mature peut-être
pour pouvoir produire tous ces tous ces
bénéfices et aujourd'hui mais
aujourd'hui on change de paradigme
notamment parce que la maturité des
marchés que j'évoqué tout à l'heure elle
est beaucoup moindre aujourd'hui qu'elle
n'était hier l'enjeu c'est plus de
partager une ressource entre différents
vendeurs parce que finalement
entre quand on ouvre à la concurrence en
2000 la seule chose qui va changer c'est
le fournisseur qui va envoyer sa facture
mais sinon c'est le même parc de
production qui produit et qui
approvisionne l'ensemble des
consommateurs à quelques à quelques
différence prêt aujourd'hui on n plus du
tout dans cette logique aujourd'hui on
est dans comment va-t-on faire pour
inciter les investisseurs à investir
dans les dizaines de mgaw de gigw dont
on a besoin pour atteindre les objectifs
de décarbonation qu'on s'est
fixé merci je passe la parole à Monsieur
peldrin
Carling monsieur meyan pardon c'est pas
c'est pardon alphabétique
excusez-moi merci monsieur le Président
merci monsieur le rapporteur bonsoir
mesdames et Messieurs les sénateur ben
moi je vais essayer de répondre un petit
peu à cette question du marché est-ce
que c'est une bonne chose une mauvaise
chose et et revenir un petit peu sur sur
l'historique pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
fait ça au départ ce marché de
l'électricité alors au départ c'est une
inspiration de ce qu'on fait les nos
amis les Britanniques Margaret chatcher
notamment qui a libéraliser le marché de
l'électricité au Royaume-Uni à une
époque où elle se battait contre contre
des contre des charbons des des des
syndicats charbonniers très puissants et
donc ça a été sa façon aussi de pouvoir
reprendre le dessus sur ces gens-là la
libéralisation du marché de
l'électricité apparaît dans l'Acte
Unique
1986 qui est suivi d'une première
directive en
1996 et depuis 1974 la France a alors
construit un parc nucléaire avec une
approche unique au monde puisque une
approche industrielle du nucléaire où on
va faire évoluer les mêmes réacteurs
avec un retour d'expérience qui nous
permet au début des années 2000 d'avoir
une
électricité deux fois moins cher que
tous les autres pays européens et
aujourd'hui nous sommes restons avec une
électricité dans la fourchette base des
pays européens euh mais le prix euh
devait augmenter de 45 % le 1er février
2022 avant l'invasion de l'Ukraine et de
100 % l'année suivante donc comment on
en est arrivé à cette situationlà
euh la directive de 1996 été transcrit
en France en l'an 2000 et donc à partir
de ce moment-là la contrainte de la
France était comment allait-elle pouvoir
préserver son électricité deux fois
moins cher que tous les autres pays
européen elle avait mis en place des
tarifs régulés qui ont toujours existé
qui consistaient à prendre le tarif de
DF fonctionnement plus développant d'y
appliquer une marge et d'avoir des
tarifs régulés réglementés pour les
particuliers les tarifs bleus pour les
petites et moyennes entreprises tarifs
jaunes et pour les grandes entreprises
tarif vert tarif régulés c'est c'est ce
dont ne veut pas bien évidemment la
Commission européenne et l'objectif de
la libéralisation Infiné et de les
supprimer dans au début des années 2000
vous avez des prix du marché alors on en
a parlé tout à l'heure avec Monsieur
perscebois le coût marginal donc le prix
du marché qui est indexé sur notamment
le prix prix du gaz la centrale
marginale mais ce prix du gaz à l'époque
il est indexé sur quoi il est indexé sur
le prix du
pétrole au début des années 2000 en
décembre 2001 vous avez la Chine qui
rejoint
l'OMC quand la Chine rejoint l'OMC le
pétrole coûte pas cher à cette époque là
le gaz coûte pas cher les prix de
l'électricité de marché sont inférieurs
au tarifs réglementés et la Chine on
connaît son développement de 2002 à 2000
2008 avec une demande de pétrole qui
augmente très fortement une offre de
pétrole contrainte et donc des prix qui
vont augmenter de 2002 à 2008 pour
atteindre 150 dollars le baril les prix
du pétrole augmentent les prix donc du
gaz augmentent et les prix de lait
l'électricité augmente à partir de 2004
2005 vous avez donc le tarif le marché
qui passe au-dessus des tarifs
réglementés la France pour réagir met en
place ce qu'on appelle le TaRTAM quel
est le TaRTAM c'est un tarif qui permet
aux entreprises qui avaient choisi au
début des années 2000 de prendre des
tarifs de marché de pouvoir revenir sur
le tarif réglementé une sorte de quelque
sorte de bouclier tarifaire de revenir
sur le tarif réglementé jaune ou vert
avec une un peu plus cher que ce tarif
réglementé ce TaRTAM est entériné en
décembre
2006 le 13 juin 2007 la Commission
européenne ouvre une procédure d'enquête
à l'encontre de la France pour aide
d'État elle veut s'intéresser justement
à ce nouveau tarif mis en place ce
TaRTAM est-ce que ce ne serait pas une
aide d'État qui irait distordre la
concurrence au niveau européen et donc
elle va vouloir s'intéresser à ça et
s'intéresser plus en profondeur à ce
tarif jaune et ce tarif vert de
l'électricité parce que les entreprises
français et les industriels auraient
alors accès à une électricité moins cher
que leurs concurrents en Europe les
tarifs Bleus ne sont pas alors concerné
cette procédure de la Commission
européenne donne naissance à une
commission chambsort commission
chambsort censait régler ce problème
avec l'Europe et donc c'est dans le
casadre de cette commission que nous la
France va réfléchir à trouver un système
qui puisse en même temps permettre au
consommateur français de bénéficier de
son avantage électricité nucléaire
historique mais aussi d'ouvrir la
concurrence puisqueà partir du 1er
juillet 2007 euh chaque français devait
pvoir choisir son opérateur
d'électricité donc cette proposition est
est est proposée à la Commission
européenne la loi nom signé en décembre
2010 et en 2012 la Commission européenne
valide la fin de ce contentieux avec la
France sous plusieurs conditions la
première c'est effectivement la création
de laarine avec EDF qui va devoir vendre
un/4 de sa production euh à euh des
fournisseur alternatif au prix de 42 €
du mgawh la France était d'ailleurs
censé euh donner à la à la commission
euh les modalités pour faire évoluer ce
prix au fur et à mesure des années elle
ne l' jamais fait et cette cette
décision 2012 entérine la fin des tarifs
jaunes et des tarifs verts le 1er
janvier 2016 qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
pour cette année et encore pour l'année
prochaine vous avez un certain nombre
d'entrepris et de PME qui payent leur
électricité à 300 € du MWh sans aucune
porte de sortie pour pouvoir revenir à
des prix plus plus
raisonnables l'arè est donc appliqué
comme on l'a dit précédemment sur 2012
2012- 2020 en fait un des impacts du
marché européen fait que les Allemands
qui ont développé beaucoup d'énergie
renouvelable l'énergie ne se stockant
pas vont pouvoir entre guillemets le
stocker chez leur voisins avec en
utilisant les les interconnexions ça a
un impact sur Ben le prix du marché
puisque les prix du marché vont être
diminuer la Cour des comptes estimée en
juillet 2022 un impact 5 € à la baisse
avec les énergies renouvelables et la
priorité réseau dont elle dispose et ça
va avoir aussi un impact sur les les
gros électriciens
EDF en France mais tous les gros
électriciens allemands effectivement qui
vont vendre moins d'électricité de leur
centrale traditionnelle puisquil y a la
priorité des énergies renouvelables et
qui vont la vendre moins cher la Cour
des comptes estime que l'arène
sur 2011- 20020 a représenté
un manque à gagner de
5,25 milliards d'euros pour pour
EDF et on arrive on arrive à la fin des
à la fin des années 2010 et
effectivement l'arine qui était
finalement une dérogation que la France
avait obtenu auprès de Bruxelles pour
que les consommateurs finaux puissent
continuer alors la dernière condition
dont j'ai pas parlé c'est ce tarif
réglementé nous allions pouvoir
conserver un tarif réglementé et ce
tarif réglementé allait être constitué
donc pour 2 tiers d'électricité
nucléaire qui nous permettait de garder
cet avantage compétitif et un/ers du
marché un/ers du marché de gros dans
ce ce que nous n'avions pas prévu alors
le dernier point et dernière point de la
recommandation de la Commission champsor
c'était que la concurrence ne se fasse
pas que sur sur l'aval mais aussi sur la
prod
et elle disait notamment
elle disait je cite la régulation doit
inciter à terme les nouveaux acteurs à
investir dans des moyens de production
une concurrence sur la fourniture
d'électricité qui dépendrait durablement
et exclusivement d'un approvisionnement
auprès deedf ne doit pas être considéré
comme une solution soutenable EDF
aujourd'hui produit 90 % de
l'électricité en France
quand
en alors EDF a aussi perdu un certain
nombre de de clients quand l'électricité
était donc inférieure à à 42 € du mgawh
les prix de gros entre entre 2015 et
2020 et quand quand les prix de gros ont
explosé à partir de ont augmenté à
partir de 18 201829 et explosé en 2021
vous avez alors tous ces fournisseurs
alternatifs qui sont revenu demander
plus d'électricité d'aren à àedf et là
vous avez un mécanisme qui fait que la
facture des Français la facture des
tarifs régulés euh alors que le
nucléaire auparavant représentait les
2/3 de la facture le nucléaire est passé
sur moins de la moitié de la facture
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'écrêement et la
part du marché qui avait été multiplié
par 4 a représenté plus de la moitié de
la facture des des Français donc
aujourd'hui nous allons la cation est en
train de se se régulariser
avec avec la baisse des des marchés de
gros est ce que ce que je voudrais une
solution qui aurait pu être envisagée
pour la suite de l'arène alors la suite
de la régulation et des tarifs
réglementé aujourd'hui donc
EDF s'est engagé à vendre son
électricité à so 70 € du mgawh on aurait
pu prendre le même le même mécanisme
cette arène et l'améliorer le modifier
ce que l'on aurait pu faire d'ailleurs
depuis 2012 et qui n'a pas été fait une
solution pour pour le se faire aurait
été par exemple d'intégrer la France
était é un champion du nucléire mais
était aussi un champion de l'hydraulique
puisque c'est un des premiers pays à
l'avoir développé la la blanche nous
aurions pu donc faire évoluer ce
mécanisme de l'arène accès régulé à
l'électric cité nucléaire historique
vers un mécanisme qu'on aurait pu
appeler l'accès régulé à l'électricité
décarbonée historique où l'on aurait
inclu le nucléaire et et l'hydraulique
cur a permis d'avoir des factures à 80 %
assis sur des capacités déjà amorties au
coût autour de 60 € du MWh et de garder
comme le suggère aussi monsieur
Percebois une part du marché de 20 %
donc réduire l'exposition du marché de
37 % dans l'arène à plus que 20 % c'est
ça qui a fait exploser le prix de le
prix de l'électricité et éviter ce qui
s'est produit depuis 3 ans et qui une
des raisons principales et qui n'a pas
été expliqué de l'explosion du prix de
l'électricité euh qui est le phénomène
de l'écrêement qui est donc le phénomène
que vous ayez des personnes qui ne
produisent que des factures pas de kilwh
qui représente 5 % 5 % de la production
française et pour ces 5 % de la
production française vous avez des
factures qui sont passées de 60 € du MWh
à 240 € du
mgawh 60 à
240 € du mgawh il suffirait de d'obliger
ces fournisseurs alternative à se
couvrir à autoproduire une partie de
leur de leur vente 25 % par exemple de
leur production pour éviter que ce que
nous avons connu ces dernières années se
prododuise je vrais finir par un dernier
point qui est des travaux qu'on que nous
avons publié avec France stratégie en
janvier 2021 sur justement la sûreté
d'approvisionnement du réseau en Europe
ce qui a permis ce marché européen c'est
effectivement l'optimisation des
interconnexions les interconnexions ne
datent pas du marché européen nous
exportions d'ailleurs plus d'électricité
avant le marché européen que depuis le
marché
européen mais ces interconnexions ont
permis un certain nombre de pays
notamment avec la baisse des prix de
gros de fermer des capacités et des
centrales pilotables des centrales à gaz
des centrales à charbon pour la France
depuis 2010 c'est 12 GW qui ont été
fermés 10 GW de centrale thermique 2 GW
de centrale nucléaire si jamais nous
n'avions pas fermé centrale nous
n'aurions pas connu une explosion du
prix de l'électricité à partir de mars
2022 puisqueen mars 2022 quand nous
avons découvert ces phénomènes de
corrosion sous contrainte sur notre parc
les prix de l'électricité avait déjà
doublé avec le gaz et ont été multiplié
à nouveau par de à cause de ce phénomène
exacerbé par la spéculation sur sur les
marchés si nous avions gardé ces
capacités qu' vous en parl tout à
l'heure nous aurions pu éviter euh une
partie de cette augmentation et ce que
concluz dans ce rapport France stratégie
c'est que c'est le manque le manque de
coordination qu'il existe aujourd'hui au
niveau des États européens l'énergie
reste une prérogative de chacun des
États-membres et que chacun des États
européens décide dans son coin de fermer
des centrales à gaz des centrales
nucléaires des centrales à charbon des
centrales pilotables qui fait que quand
vous êtes sur un bien qui ne se stock
pas et que vous supprimez toutes vos
marges de sécurité et bien vous vous
donnez toutes les conditions pour que il
y ait des événements comme il s'est
passé il y a 2 ans avec des prix qui
dépassent les 1000 € du mgawh pour je
vous rappelle une éleric électricité
produite à 60 euh qui se passe
merci merci Monsieur man monsieur le
rapporteur merci merci pour Cees rappel
historique c'est toujours intéressant
d'avoir effectivement le la
perspective vous avez compris que notre
commission elle elle se projetait plutôt
vers l'avenir et voir ce que l'on peut
faire à partir de maintenant bien sûr
avec l'expérience du passé et donc je je
vais vous poser juste une question sur
le sur
l'arène est-ce que vous pensez
aujourd'hui qu'il faut que laarinene
évolue est-ce que le le prix déjà bon
visiblement personne ne veut supprimer
laarine avant fin 2025 est-ce que le
prix doit évoluer s'il évolue il aura
forcément des conséquences sur la
facture des usagers euh j'imagine donc
si on l'augmentait de 20 % admettons
qu'on est ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure perdu 20 % depuis sa création
euh est-ce qu'il faudrait passer à 50 €
ou 52 quel conséquences sur la facture
et euh est-ce que le le jour où ça va
disparaître donc fin 202 5 si c'est
remplacé par les 70 € est-ce que on
passerait de 42 à 70
€ alors sur alors sur laaren
effectivement on peut dire que si on
augmentait son prix de 40 50 60 € ça
aurait un impact sur la facture la
réponse est qu' ça n'en aurait pas pour
l'instant parce pourquoi parce que avec
la méthode de calcul de l'arè de tarif
réglementé pardon le tarif réglementé
vous allez regarder les deux sur le
tarif réglementé qui est payé
aujourd'hui par les
Français le français paye le kilwh le
mgawh 125 € d'accord pour un coût de
production à 60 qu' aujourd'hui on le
paye 125 parce que on est dans la partie
du marché qui représente 55 % de la
facture d'accord le nucléaire c'est 45 %
de la facture pour 70 % de la
production 55 % de la facture donc c'est
donc le gaz et donc sur les deux
dernières années vous aviez des prix
élevés qui ont déjà baissé l'an dernier
et qui vont continuer à baisser l'année
prochaine et donc on s'oriente
vraisemblablement avec le même mécanisme
vers une baisse des prix de
l'électricité l'an prochain à partir du
1er février
2025 y compris avec le rattrapage prévu
euh de taxes qui est encore normalement
de 10 € du 10 € du MWh
donc on on pourrait au aujourd'hui avec
la baisse des prix de gros et en mettant
en place peut-être ce mécanisme pour
éviter ce ce cet écrêtement qui est
vraiment notre problème numéro 1 le fait
que nous ayons finalement raté à mettre
en place une concurrence au niveau de la
production que finalement nous ayons
majoritairement des producteurs de
facture et en fait c'est ces producteurs
de factures qui ont fait sans produire
d'électricité exploser les prix on est
quand même sur euh quand on parle vous
parlez de la libéralisation du marché
pourquoi est-ce qu'on libéralise un
marché souvent il y a deux objectifs
soit on améliore le niveau de service au
même prix ou soit on baisse le prix au
même niveau de service quand on regarde
l'évolution des tarifs réglementés
l'électricité pour le consommateur
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait depuis
l'ouverture à la concurrence depuis 2007
n fait qu'augmenter comme le rappelait
monsieur perscebois notamment avec la
CSPE qui a permis de financer les
énergies renouvelables je pense que
c'est une question que vous devrez vous
poser euh dans cette commission à quoi
servent ces énergies renouvelables dans
le mix électrique français quel est le
service rendu par ces énergies
renouvelables contribuent-elle à la
sécurité d'approvisionnement
complète-t-elle euh ce que fait le le
nucléaire se substitue-t-elle en partie
à notre électricité nucléaire à quel
prix le le nucléaire les énergies
renouvelables intermittentes pour moi
sont très pertinentes dans des pays
ayant une électricité forcément carbonée
avec du charbon avec du gaz comme au
Royaume-Uni comme en Allemagne où elles
ont permis de remplacer et donc de faire
diminuer les émissions de CO2 en France
elles vont se substituer principalement
à une électricité qui est déjà
décarbonée elles n'ont pas fait diminuer
nos consommation d'électricité d'origine
thermique euh donc ça c'est des
questions je pense qui qu'il faudra
répondre parce que c'est elles qui sont
en partie responsables non sement
l'augmentation depuis ces dernières
années mais du rattrapage de TI CFE
anciennement CSPE même si désormais les
renouvelables sont financés par par une
autre
taxe monsieur
Lurel en vous écoutant j'aimerais vous
poser une question politiquement
incorrecte j'espère ne pas choquer mes
collègues
euh si on se pose la question de
l'utilité et de l'efficience de la
production des énergies renouvelables et
et leur stabilité leur stockage et leur
introduction sur les réseaux
euh est-ce que on peut se poser
légitimement la question que compte tenu
de la nature de notre électricité qui
est déjà décarboné qui est même si le
pourcentage a diminué en terme d'énergie
nucléaire que le système tel qu'il a
fonctionné jusqu'ici et peut-être
jusqu'en 2025 ça a consisté à donneré
une sorte de faveur une sorte d'avantage
compétitif euh au renouvelables au
charbon au gaz je la dire à l'Allemagne
est-ce que le fait que au niveau
européen on a décidé de ce système là et
que la reine bon va participer pour un
certain pourcentage du prix des tarifs
réglementair et que le reste se fera sur
le marché c'est bien ça ça peut-être de
l'éolien ça du renouvelable ça peut-être
du gaz bon on a pris le gaz comme
indicateur
d'adossement quelques années après avec
les alliats climatique avec le grand
carinage et tout ça on se rend compte
que on a
favorisé on a
défavorisé la France dans cette affaire
là est-ce que je peux poser la question
comme ça ou ou est-ce que elle est
indue je pense que la la question que
vous posez c'est quel a été pour la
France le bénéfice ou de la
libéralisation du marché
d'électricité quand vous êtes un acteur
historique intégré monopole Unic monde
et l'électricité
et deux fois moins cher que T
voisins effectivement les les bénéfices
vont pas être évidents une fois de plus
quand on l'intérêt principal du marché
aujourd'hui ça a été ce marché c'est
quoi c'est des échanges journaliers
intrajournaliers entre les
paysugment augmenter les connexions
entre les les différents pays et donc
optimisation de ces
échanges est-ce que ça a eu un impact
pour le consommateur final français qui
payit son électricit C deux fois moins
cher oui mais mauvais puisqu'il la paye
désormais il la paye désormais presque
au même prix que les autres pays
européens EDF a été découpé en morceau
hein puisqu'on a d'abord enlevé RTE puis
on a aussi enlevé une alors c'est pas
queedf bien évidemment ça a été fait
dans tous les autres paysin ça n'était
pas qu'une ce n'était pas qu'une qu'un
régime réservé à la France mais c'est le
principe de la de la libéral isation où
on va découper les entreprises entre
elles donc EDF a été désoptimisé ODF a
été désoptimisé EDF a perdu aussi je
vous ai dit il manque à gagner avec
finalement des fournisseurs qu'est-ce
qu'ils font à la place deedf fournir des
factures bon ben voilà ça c'est 5
milliards d'euros de manque à gagner
pour F entre 2011 et
2021 et et
aujourd'hui la question des énergies
renouvelables en France
euh ce qui se substitue aujourd'hui en
France vous avez quand même vous payez
deux fois l'électricité d'accord quand
vous avez du vent ou du soleil et que le
nucléaire réduit sa production parce que
vous devez avoir en permanence la
production et la consommation égale mais
la centrale nucléaire vous la payez
quand même c'est le même coût puisque le
coût du nucléaire c'est principalement
un coût fixe le coût du carburant étant
de le coût du carburant le coût du de
l'uranium était moins de moins de 10 %
donc vous payez deux fois l'électricité
et c'est la raison pour laquelle les
prix
augmentent donc
aujourd'hui la France ben c'est très
simple en 2000 elle avait l'électricité
de fois moins cher que les pays
européens elle a perdu cet avantage
compétitif qui faisait que les
industriels venaient en France pour
s'implanter merci on va passer à monur
monsieur Plerin Carlin s'il vous plaît
et puis après on refera un tour de table
pour les questions Daniel salement a
demandé la parole je lui donnerai tout à
l'heure bien volontiers allez-y monsieur
très bien merci Monsieur monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les les
sénateurs donc je comprends que je peux
me concentrer sur mon propos liminire et
revenir après sur des propos disons
pouvant vous induire en erreur qui ont
pu être proféré à l'instant tenez voilà
vous êtes libre de de vos propos mais
centrez-vous sur le je le ferai plus t
initial après et après on discutera à la
fin ou si vous tout à fait et notamment
vous orienter vers des des personnes qui
sont qui sont réellement expertes de ces
sujets et que je pense pourrait vous
donner des informations intéressantes
là-dessus je vais articuler mon propos
liminire en en trois temps d'abord on va
dézoomer essayer de comprendre quel est
le rôle de l'électricité dans le système
énergétique euh puisque pour ce qui
s'agit de la facture on peut pas penser
l'électricité sans penser plus
généralement son rôle dans le système
énergétique ensuite je vais j'ai essayé
de résumer en une DI euh tout
l'écosystème du secteur électrique donc
j'ai fait quelques raccourcis je m'en
excuse auparavant euh et enfin je
zoomerai sur un point important qui me
semble le rôle de notamment de la
production électrique renouvelable sur
les marchés de gros au cours des trois
dernières années en m'appuyant sur une
étude de de l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie qui un organisme de de
l'OCDE donc tout d'abord sur le premier
point un élément qui est important à
rappeler notamment il y a un décalage
entre la la la perception de la
dépendance énergétique en France dans le
débat public et sa réalité ici ce que
vous avez c'est la consommation
d'énergie finale en France l'énergie
finale c'est l'énergie qu'on met dans
les machines je reviendrai sur ça plus
tard et contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait croire qu'andon écoute les
débats à la radio ou à la télé la
première source d'énergie dont on dépend
en France c'est d'abord le pétrole et
deuxièmement euh une autre énergie
fossile qui est qui est le gaz qui est
le gaz fossile donc rien que le pétrole
et le gaz représentent les 2/3 de
l'énergie qu'on qu'on consomme en France
euh on en utilise très peu pour faire de
l'électricité on utilise un tout petit
peu de pétrole pour faire de
l'électricité mais le pétrole sert
notamment à faire bah rouler des camions
des voitures des tracteurs et cetera euh
le gaz fossile est utilisé pour
différents éléments notamment pour
chauffer euh des bâtiments il y a plus
de Français qui se chauffe au au gaz que
de Français qui se chauffe à
l'électricité même si le le gaz a un
rôle critique dans le marchéélectricité
comme ça a été bien expliqué et le
nucléaire et les énergies renouvelables
représenter en 2019 respectivement 17 et
16 % aujourd'hui on sera un peu moins de
nucléaire un peu plus d'énergie
d'énergie renouvelable vu la la
constante baisse de production du
nucléaire depuis les années 2000
jusqu'aujourd'hui même si on espère
enfin depuis 2022 jusqu'en 2022 pardon
même si on a eu un un petit rebond mais
on reste bien en dessous et on restera
malheureusement bien en dessous des
niveaux de production nucléaire des
années des années
2000 un deuxième mythe que j'aimerais
déconstruire pardon pour sur le
nucléaire on a perdu Fessenheim mais euh
qui a été fermé mais en dehors de
Fessenheim si si on tient pas compte de
Fessenheim c'est on est on est dans les
mêmes capacité ou est-ce qu'au fur à
mesure du temps c'est c'est moins
productif le nucléaire donc là ce que
vous avez ce que vous avez ici en jaune
c'est la production nucléaire en France
en terraw année après année donc j'ai
pas vérifié si le pic on on l'a atteint
en 2004 ou 5 de mémoire enfin vous voyez
qu'en gros on a un niveau très élevé et
stable il y a des variations annuelles
hein ça dépend de quand est-ce qu'on
fait de la maintenance et cetera euh et
vous avez une baisse qui est entamé en
2015 feston joue un rôle làdedans mais
un rôle mineur puisque c'est que de
réacteurs sur 57 ou ne9f je ne sais plus
combien en avait euh à ce moment-là et
vous voyez une baisse par exemple entre
2019 et 2020 évidemment entre 21 et 22
on verra ce qui se passe à l'avenir
effectivement 2023 est mieux que 2022
qui é un peu une année une annu
horibilis mais si vous mutorisez un
raccourcier rapide si jamais vous avez
dans votre parc de de de voitures 60
voitures et qu'elles ont toutes 10 15
ans ben il y a plus de chance qu'il y en
ait certaines d'entre elles qui doivent
passer un peu de temps au garage pour
changer quelques pièces vous pourrez pas
les utiliser comme si c'était 15 ou 20
voiture complètement
neuve donc l'autre myth que je voulais
déconstruire c'est l'idée que la France
est une exception dans le le paysage
énergétique européen là vous avez le
même graphique mais vous voyez l'Union
européenne donc je vais juste faire une
alternance entre les deux graphiques he
là vous avez la
France et là vous avez l'Union
européenne et donc donc la France est un
pays qui est clairement dans la famille
européenne comme point commun avec la
moyenne européenne bah on est
hyperdpendant du pétrole hyperdpendant
du gaz fossile euh comme point commun
aussi aujourd'hui probablement en 2023
24 les énergies renouvelables sont
probablement la troisème source
d'énergie en France comme c'est le cas
du coup déjà en Europe depuis quelques
temps et la différence par contre et ce
qui fait que la France effectivement un
frère différent dans cette famille
européenne c'est une beaucoup moins
grande dépendance au au charbon en
France et un plus grand disons un rôle
plus grand du nucléaire et les deux sont
évidemment liés il y a eu un choix mais
qui date des années
70 et 80 en faveur d'une production
électrique en France qui repose beaucoup
sur le nucléaire autour de 70 % là dans
beaucoup d'États européens l'Allemagne a
été cité mais on peut aussi penser à la
Pologne ou la Bulgarie ou la Roumanie on
a aussi une production de de charbon qui
est plus plus
significatif donc voilà pour le rôle de
l'électricité dans le secteur
énergétique c'est c'est un enjeu clé euh
mais ça n'est que si je puis dire disons
25 à 35 % de l'enjeu énergétique dans
dans son ensemble
ensuite si on essaie de comprendre quel
est ce cette ce que vous avez appelé
l'écosystème euh de l'électricité j'ai
essayé de résumer ça j'aurais pas le
temps de rentrer dans chaque boîte on
pourrait passer 2 heures quasiment sur
chacune de ces des des Boutes C encadré
mais ce que là vous voyez tout à votre
gauche ce sont tous les segments la
chaîne de valeur en partant de l'usager
euh c'est-à-dire le le le boulanger ou
ou moi-même qui utilise de l'électricité
au quotidien pour remonter jusqu'à la
source d'énergie initiale alors soit
c'est c'est c'est le vent qui souffle
sur dunkererque le soleil qui rayonne
sur Toulouse ou l'uranium du Niger ou le
gaz de Russie selon la manière dont une
source d'énergie a été captée pour euh
pour transformer ça en en électricité
euh quelques points sur lesquels
j'aimerais insister c'est qu'en fait
idéalement si vous en avez z le temps
dans votre commission d'enquête je vous
encourage à regarder en fait tous ces
éléments là pour comprendre vraiment
l'intégralité du
système un enjeu par exemple très
concret si vous me permettez de donner
un exemple issu de de de de ma vie du du
Calvados si vous avez un ménage qui vit
en milieu rural qui se chauffe avec une
cuve à gaz ou au fuel d'ailleurs c'est
même logique et cette personne là à un
moment en fait person a besoin c'est pas
d'électricité en tant que tel ou même de
fi ou même de gaz elle a besoin de
chaleur besoin de chauffer son logement
si jamais cette personn là peut investir
par exemple dans une pompe à chaleur ça
va augmenter sa consommation
d'électricité elle va passer du gaz ou
du pétrole d'un côté à de l'électricité
pour sa pompe à chaleur de l'autre du
coup sa facture d'électricité va
évidemment augmenter mais sa facture
énergétique va baisser puisque le le
surcût de l'électricité pour alimenter
la pompe à chaleur va être beaucoup plus
faible que le prix du gaz ou le prix du
file pour obtenir le même service
énergétique et donc du coup quand quand
monsieur le rapporteur vous disiez voilà
il faut avoir les les prix les moins
volatiles possibles la question c'est
bah absolument mais à quel niveau vous
vous situez et moi je vous encourage
notamment quand on regarde à long terme
à se poser la question des prix de
l'électricité toujours dans ce contexte
plus général de
l'énergie un prix de l'électricité qui
augmenterait de 10 % ou de 20 % ou de 30
% à long terme si jamais ça vient
remplacer une voiture à pétrole qui est
remplacée par une voiture électrique un
chauffage au fuel ou à gaz qui est
remplacé par un chauffage à électricité
il est prix entre le pétrolle et le gaz
d'un côté et le vecteur électrique
restera important il y a des manières
pour les déc d'influencer ça et
notamment une manière de taxer
différemment ces chosesl monsieur
montoger parlait du du prix carbone
aujourd'hui en France le prix carbone
est plus important sur
l'électricité que sur le gaz de
chauffage par exemple donc pour
l'instant le la la politique en terme de
prix
carbone pénalise l'électricité vis-à-vis
du gaz fossile ou vis-à-vis du file ou
du diesel par exemple ce qui est un ce
qui est un choix ce est un choix
politique on rentrera pas dans dans dans
tous les détails beaucoup a déjà été a
été mentionné mais je comptais m'appuyer
sur cet enjeu là de des usagers qui
avaient pas encore été mentionnés je
reviens pas sur les enjeux de réseau qui
ont été qui ont été parfaitement traités
et du coup me focaliser sur l'unité de
production dont ce qui influence le prix
alors il y a la reine dont on a déjà
beaucoup parlé mais aussi le prix sur le
le marché de
gros et donc là je je vais m'appuyer
j'appuie la fin de mon propos sur une
étude qui est parue du coup à l'été
dernier de l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie et qui mesure de manière
précise comment est-ce que une certaine
quantité d'électricité renouvelable
produite entre 2021 et 2023 a permis de
faire baisser les prix de gros
l'électricité je suis désolé pour le
graphique qui suit c'est pas moi qui l'
fait c'est c'est eu donc c'est tout
petit ce que vous voyez en bas c'est
l'évolution du prix de l'électricité sur
le marché de gros dans la moyenne
européenne et ce que vous voyez en haut
c'est ce que ce prix aurait été si
jamais on avait arrêté d'installer des
énergies renouvelables en
2021 vous voyez qu'il aurait été plus
élevé donc si jamais on avait fait ce
que certains proposent à savoir un
moratoire sur le déploiement d'énergie
renouvelable on aurait arrêté
d'installer des éoliennes des paux
solaires du coup on aurait eu une baisse
de l'offre de l'électricité par rapport
à ce qui s'est passé réellement et sur
un marché à demande constante si jamais
il y a moins d'offre les prix augmentent
donc là ce que vous voyez c'est l'écart
entre le prix réel en bas et un prix
plus élevé qui selon l'Agence nationale
de l'énergie aurait été le prix de
l'électricité sur les marchés de gros si
jamais on avait mis fin au déploiement
des énergies renouvelables en 2021 vous
voyez que cet écart de prix grandit à
travers le temps c'est logique parce
qu'évidemment il y a plus de nouvelles
éoliennes en 2023 que de nouvelles
éoliennes en 2000 en 2021 par exemple et
donc là quand vous regardez ça vous
pouvez me dire mais monsieur monsieur
pin Carlin pourquoi vous est-ce que vous
nous montrez ça la différence est à
peine visible sur ce graphique on peut à
peine voir euh du coup pour exprimer les
économies que ça qui ont été réalisées
euh j'ai oublié le le chiffre mais les
économies réalisées pour l'intégralité
de l'Union européenne c'est de l'ordre
de 100 milliards d'euros sur cette
période de 3
ans l'analyse de l'Agence nationale de
l'énergie donne un un dégradé pays par
pays et si on rapporte du coup ces
économies permises par les énergies
renouvelables par habitant on obtient ça
c'est ce que j'ai fait spécialement pour
vous donc là j'ai juste pris les
économies je les ai annualisé je les
divisé par nombre d'habitant et et à ma
ma surprise d'ailleurs le premier
bénéficiaire de ça c'est la
France donc du coup ce que nous dit
cette étude de l'Agence internationale
de l'énergie c'est pas simplement que
les énergies renouvelables font baisser
près l'électricité ce qui un élément en
tout cas sur marché gros c'est c'est
quelque chose qui fait l'objet d'un d'un
consensus c'est que là on a une
estimation précise chiffrée avec un
modèle qui moi me semble robuste même si
on peut toujours questionner des des
modèles qui sont faits
excusez-moi
les alors ce que l'étude ne dit pas
c'est qui a bénéficié de cette
différence de prix et ce que je tiens
aussi à souligner c'est que encore une
fois on est ou peut-être pour le dire
autrement sans les énergies
renouvelables les prix de 2022 auraient
été encore plus élevés que ce qu'ils
nont
été je je je formule le le même fait
mais d'unutrere excusez-moi parce que
c'est c'est pas mal d'être un peu
interactif là par rapport à vos vos
présentations mais c'est prix TTC donc
vous vous parliez là où ça c'est prix
sur marché de gros c'est prix sur marché
de gros c'est
pasit et c'est un peu surprenant sur
votre sur votre tableau la France est
plutôt en retard par rapport aux autres
pays et notamment par rapport à
l'Allemagne sur les les renouvelables
c'estàd que moi on a de renouvelable
plus on gagne alors c'est en fait un
marché européen et donc du coup c'est
moi ça me surprend un peu mais non mais
justement je je vais je vais vous
expliquer ça tout de
suite en fait justement parce qu'on a ce
marché européens les consommateurs
français bénéficient aussi des baisses
de prix d'électricité permis par les
renouvelables allemandes ou les
renouvelables espagnoles puisque du coup
plus il y a d'électricité renouvelable
j'ai envie de dire à la limite presque
où on veut en Europe je je je force un
peu le trait hein mais que l'éolienne
elle soit au large du Pays-Basque
français ou au large du Pays-Basque
espagnol ça change pas grand-chose pour
le prix du marché de gros hein euh idem
pour une éolienne qu'elle soit d'un côté
du RIN ou de l'autre parce qu'on a ce
marché européen de l'électricité il y a
de fortes chances que les électrons
puissent Franch la frontière écoutez moi
moi là là on va pas avoir le temps dans
cette audition de d'approfondir mais
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut quand
même qu'on approfondisse pas mal parce
que c'est pas intuitif ce que vous dites
euh c'est d'autant moins intuitif qu'on
est plutôt exportateur naturel
d'électricité même si en 2022 ça a été
une année horbilis en la matière mais à
partir du moment où on n'est pas on est
plutôt exportateur on n'est pas très
importateur moi je suis un peu surpris
que c'est c'est autant d'influence voyez
ce tableau- là moi il me surprend
énormément je me dis je me dis comment
il a été calculé il faut toujours
regarder derrière comment comment on
calcule tout cela voilà bon je vous
enverrai avec grand plaisir le tableur
Excel ça ça ça mérite d'être regardé de
près parce que c'est vraiment pas
intuitif moi moi ce que je vous
encourage à faire c'est inviter les
auteurs de cette étude l'Agence
nationale de l'énergie c'est le CDE
c'est à je sais pas moi 2 km d'ici hein
ouais voilà je vous encourage à faire
moi moi la seule chose que j'ai fait
c'est j'ai pris leurs chiffres qui sont
des chiffres par état et j'ai divisé par
la population c'est c'est c'est aussi
simple aussi simple que ça pour qu'on
comprenne excuse -moi pour qu'on
comprenne comment ça fonctionne quelle
est la raison de cela c'est un effet
volume c'est-à-dire que plus vous mettez
d'électricité sur le marché plus ça fait
baisser les prix et donc effectivement
si les énergies renouvlaables produisent
de l'électricité ça fait un volume
supplémentaire donc automatiquement ça
fait baisser le prix est-ce que c'est
juste ça ou est-ce que c'est le fait que
le nr de par sa nature a un prix de
production moindre et donc le fait de
les mettre sur le marché ça fait baisser
le prix alors oui pleinement à la
première question et oui partiellement à
la deuxième c'estàdire que ce qui permet
ça c'est effectivement une augmentation
de l'offre électrique c'est que il y a
il y a plus d'électricité grâce au
l'inallation d'énergie renouvelable pour
être tout à fait complet vous auriez eu
le même résultat si jamais il y avait eu
aussi une nouvelle centrale nucléaire
connectée par
exemple alors pas une centrale forcément
à charbon parce que la centrale à
charbon elle ne va pas vendre à un prix
bah c'est ce qui a été expliqué
auparavant pour que une centrale pour
qu'un un générateur d'électricité qui
utilise soit du charbon soit du gaz
accepte de vendre il faut au moins qui
rentre dans ses coûts alors que pour
l'électricité renouvelable au nucléaire
le coût marginal d'utilisation est très
très faible du coup ce qui permet de
faire baisser de manière structurelle le
prix du marché de gros Daniel riller
oui merci président est-ce qu'on aurait
eu le même résultat si notre capacité de
production nucléaire et hydro était au
niveau
historique c'est une question que je
vous encourage à poser aux personnes de
l'agence nationale deénergie je pense
que non parce qu'on n pas sur les mêmes
ordre de grandeur euh mais ce sera
vérifié oui mais il aura il y aurait
même petit déffet effectivement non
c'est sûr que si on avait pas eu de
schess en 2022 on aurait une production
hydroélectrique plus importante et
effectivement un prix d'électricité plus
bas oui tout à fait là je vous dis juste
que ça ça a été modélisé spécifiquement
sur l'éolien et le solaire mais encore
une fois toute source d'énergie à faible
coût marginal donc ça inclu l'éolien et
le solaire mais aussi l'hydroélectricité
aussi nucléaire si jamais il y avait une
hausse de la production en 21 22 23 on
aurait eu aussi cet effet
là je peux conclure
oui allez-y oui oui il y a le phénomène
oui il y a le phénomène des frais fixes
c'est-à-dire que si vous avez un un
outil pilotable que vous arrêtez pour
effectivement injecter à la place du
renouvelable les frais fixes continuent
toujours sur l'outil qui n'injecte pas
pour ça que c'est je je je rejoins le
propos de notre rapporteur Président
c'est un sujet qui va falloir vraiment
creuser je veux pas allonger parce que
sinon pour pour dire autrement le on dit
souvent que le prix duélectricité indexé
sur le prix du gaz c'est un raccourci le
le prix du gaz a un impact sur le prix
de l'électricité un certain nombre
d'heures par an qui sont les heures où
on a besoin de ça et donc du coup
mécaniquement si vous ajouter de la
production électrique renouvelable ou
nucléaire bah vous réduisez ce nombre
d'heures peut-être que d'une heure ou 2h
ou 3h par Anin mais j'ai envie de dire
c'est toujours ça prix il a il y a un
point qui est qui qui est pas abordé qui
qui me paraît important à à prendre rend
compte si j'ai bien compris les choses
c'est ce qu'on appelle les externalités
euh les
flexibilités je regarde monsieur
perscebois c'est lui qui m'a appris ça à
travers à travers ses écrits euh pour ce
type de de de de production renouvelable
moi je je suis pas dans une logique
d'opposer les modes de production les
uns aux autres mais quand on parle de
renouvelable les externalités les
flexibilités c'est quand même un poste
extrêmement important qui pèse lourd et
qui pèse d'autant plus lourd que ce type
de de production non pilotable et
développé est-ce que est-ce que cet
aspect là des choses qui finit par peser
sur la facture du du client final est
pris en compte dans ce que vous nous
présentez alors ça ça regarde que le
prix sur le marché de gros donc ça
regarde juste un élément donc ça une
approche de marché et pas du tout une
approche par les par les coûts de
production et et les coûts induits c'est
c'est vraiment une analyse
économétrique qui regarde ce qui s'est
passé qui bâtit un scénario alternatif
on aurait mis un moratoire sur les
énergies renouvelables et qui regarde
l'impact sur le l'évolution enfin qui
estime plutôt la différence du du prix
sur le marché de gros et à la fin ça
vous donne ça vous donne ça vous pouvez
évidemment inclure d'autres éléments je
vous encourage par contre quand vous
intégrez les externalités à le faire
pour toutes les externalités et non pas
à choisir d'intégrer ce
quienduend et non mais par exemple pour
vous donner pour vous donner essayer de
bien
travailleress tout à fait euh le
typiquement un des enjeux qui est
importants clairement sur le renouvable
et notamment lorsqu'on fait comme ça
semble être le le le la préférence de la
France pour l'instant qu' qu'on choisit
de privilégier l'éolien en mer par
rapport à l'éolien terrestre ça augmente
le coût de raccordement au réseau
puisque l'éolien
terrestre pas du tout là-dedans je je
dis juste voilà le coût de raccordement
au réseau par
contre subvention tout ça ça y est pas
c'est des marchés c'est des prix de
marché donc tout ça c'est c'est pas pris
en compte voilà encore une fois je vous
donne juste je dis c'est c'est c'est un
élément qui me semble intéressant pour
nourrir votre votre réflexion pour
terminer sur je vous laisse conclure
allez-y pour terminer peut-être sur le
sur le volet du raccordement vous pouvez
aussi financer le raccordement réseau
par des injections de capitao par
exemple dans che RTE c'est quelque chose
chose qui est tout à fait possible
puisque une fois raccordé c'est un actif
qui qui est rentable on n'est pas obligé
d'augmenter le prix d'électricité pour
financer le le raccordement pour
conclure la difficulté que que que vous
avez c'est évidemment de décider dans
l'incertitude euh sur l'électricité une
certitude c'est que la place
deélectricité est de plus en plus
centrale dans not système électrique
énergétique pardon la question c'est
jusqu'où et à vous de décider si vous
voulez inclure ou exclure ces choses-là
parmi les énergies renouvelables enfin
en gros en France qu on parle énergies
renouvaable on parle éolien et sola
photovoltaïque il y a énormément
d'autres énergies renouvelables et
notamment qui sont pas du tout en train
de produire deélectricité je pense
notamment au Solair thermique et plus
vous avez de Solair thermique bah plus
vous allégez la pression sur le réseau
sur le réseau électrique le nucléaire la
production est en baisse en baisse
tendantielle de combien ça je je ne sais
pas et quel sera le coût à la fois de la
modernisation du parc nucléaire existant
du coup des nouvelles centrales là il y
a beaucoup d'interrogations et les
récentes nouvelles d'le point 6 sont
plutôt mauvaise celles par contre venant
de falland sont plutôt plutôt positives
en tout cas celles de l'an dernière
ouioui l'éolien pareil il y a une
opposition importante qui est assez
singulière en France par rapport au
reste de de des états des États
européens est-ce que ça quelque chose là
est amené à évoluer ou pas à l'horizon
2035 en tout cas ce qu'on peut dire et
c'est l'intérêt à mon avis l'étude de
l'Agence nationale de l'énergie c'est
que tout sous ég par ailleurs plus on
installe desoliennes plus on a un prix
d'électricité qui est qui est qui est
modéré et pour finir sur un dernier
point parce que je vois que le président
regarde sa
montre dernier point surtout si vous
regardez à 2035 2050 un point central
qui n'a pas encore été abordé c'est
l'adaptation au changement climatique
c'est un enjeu qui est complètement
dimensionnant et sur tous les enjeux du
secteur électrique
euh des vagues de chaleur à 45 50°gr
c'est plus de besoin de refroidissement
ça veut dire que peut-être on va de plus
en plus devoir s'occuper d'une pointe de
consommation non pas l'hiver ce à quoi
on est habitué mais l'été pour refroidir
des êtres humains mais aussi refroidir
de la nourriture refroidir des des
machines ça on aussi un impact sur la
production on voit déjà que la baisse de
la production électrique hydroélectrique
pardon en France et au moins
probablement parti lié aux sécheresses
qui elles-mêmes sont lié au des
règlements climatique avec aussi des
enjeux de gestion des barrages ou de
plus en plus il faut se poser la
question de où est l'eau entre laamont
et laaval pour d'autres besoins type
tourisme agriculture et cetera et enfin
sur le transport puisque le l'
changement climatique c'est plus de
vagues de chaleur c'est plus d'incendie
et du coup plus de problèmes et moi je
Seris curieux mais j'ai pas encore vu ça
quel sera l'impact du changement
climatique sur l'augmentation des coûps
de réseau lié aux impacts de ce
changement climatique sur sur nos
réseaux électriques merci je vais donner
la parole à Dan salon qui l'avait
demandé juste une une petite question
vous vous je vous en remercie donc vous
vous référez à cette étude de l'agence
internationale de de l'énergie euh on
peut tout autant valablement se référer
à l'étude de RTE sur les futurs
énergétiques 20150 pour pour travailler
au niveau de notre commission pour vous
elle est
elle est de très très grande qualité
c'est juste qu'e pas du tout la même
chose c'est vraiment une autre POS une
question complètement différente euh
mais l'étude de de de RTE euh et moi en
tout cas de ce que j'ai vu l'étude la
plus aboutie la plus complète et la plus
consensuelle qui soit et qui en plus je
trouve à l'avantage de proposer au
décideurs une diversité de scénarios de
mémoire il y en a six qui sont
structurants qui vous permettent
d'éclairer scientifiquement les choix
politiques que vous avez à faire merci
Monsieur
Daniel merci monsieur le Président bon
et on a deux exposés de fort intéressant
mais fort contradictoire également euh
je pense que Monsieur man vous a fait un
brillant exposé pronucléaire et
complètement antirenouvelable j'aimerais
bien que vous m'expliquiez pourquoi on
paye deux fois vous avez dit qu'on avait
payé deux fois notre électricité
euh parce qu'on avait un un outil qui
nous permettait le nucléaire d'avoir de
de l'énergie et qu'on payait en plus les
renouvelables j'ai pas bien compris
votre exposé
euh moi je comprends que les
renouvelables dans un premier temps
effectivement ont eu besoin d'un soutien
public ça c'est très clair mais je crois
que le parc nucléaire en a bénéficié
aussi dans un temps un peu plus lointain
et il en aura besoin dans dans l'avenir
je pense il faut se projeter également
sur le le temps futur et déjà dans les
10 années à venir où notre parc
nucléaire ne sera pas en capacité pour
absorber l'augmentation de la
consommation d'énergie attendu et donc
là on aura besoin des renouvelables les
renouvelables effectivement ce comme je
disais tout à l'heure énergie émergente
a eu un coût des coûts assez importants
dans sa phase de de développement
aujourd'hui on est plutôt mais vous me
direz peut-être le contraire mais on est
plutôt sur un coup omégaw qui est qui
est très maîtrisé avec un ééolien qui
est plutôt aux alentours de de 55 60 €
lesolien terrestre les l'éolien en mer
un petit peu plus peut-être 70 mais par
rapport à ce qui est attendu pour le
futur nucléaire ou aujourd'hui on est
plutôt sur les 70 € le mgawh je pense
qu'on a et sans doute si on voit les
dérapages qui ont eu lieu sur
flamandville on sera sûrement sur des
coûts bien bien supérieurs euh voilà
j'aimerais bien que vous m'expliquiez un
peu
plus pourquoi les énergies renouvelables
pour vous ont nous ont coûté beaucoup
plus cher et sur l'autre graphique là
bon j'ai sûrement beaucoup apprendre je
comprends pas pourquoi l'Italie n'a pas
bénéficié du tout de la production des
énergies renouvelables en Europe pour
pour chacun des des Italiens a priori
eux les électrons qui se promènent sur
tout le marché européen ça l'URA pas
bénéficié du tout donc j'ai euh des
exposés où j'ai beaucoup
d'interrogations merci merci Daniel je
vais vous donner la la parole est-ce que
des collègues souhaitent rajouter des
des questions parce que on va redonner
la parole une dernière fois à nos quatre
invités donc on va prendre les questions
François Bonon
oui merci pour vos vos
explications je voudrais revenir sur sur
l'étude RTE parce que moi je souvenir
qu'en en 2020- 2021 quand RTE a fait son
études il nous montrait que la la
demande en électricité à l'horizon 2050
avec toujours vous avez évoqué les six
scénarios serait en baisse de de 40 % ce
qu' avait ce qui était surprenant non
non non mais je je je je n'invente rien
c'est c'est ce que nous a présenté RT
l'époque et puis depuis RTE a ressorti
une é a ressorti une étude où il
montrait que la en énergie oui et en en
mon et en énergie finale voilà et en
montrant que le la demande enélectricité
augmenterait de 40 % ce qui nous paraît
déjà beaucoup plus cohérent euh donc un
peu surpris sur un sujet aussi important
il pu y avoir des des distorsions aussi
fortes en aussi peu de temps je sais pas
si vous avez des explications mais enfin
moi je je j' petit souci par rapport à
ça
merci Mo moi je je voudrais revenir sur
votre déclaration monsieur mean selon
laquelle aujourd'hui le tarif réglementé
coûte 125 € du mgawh alors que le coût
de production est à 60 € du
mgawh la question que M concitoyens vont
me poser donc que je vous relaisse c'est
où est passé l'argent où est passé la
différenceavenir dans reen et dans les
tarifs réglementés il y a pas le coût de
remplacement il y a les charges
opérationnelles il y a euh euh tout
l'amortissement mais il y a pas les
investissements nécessaires pour le
remplacement c'est bien
ça comment faire ça comment financer ça
je vais vous donner la parole pour
conclure monsieur Percebois si vous
voulez bien je vais donner la la parole
s'il y a pas d'autres question de mes
collègues à Monsieur meyan d'abord et
ensuite aux autres personnes alors donc
vous m'avez poser une question pourquoi
est-ce que je j'affirme que nous payons
deux fois
l'électricité en fait quand donc le parc
nucléaire effectivement a été construit
alors on dit souvent que c'est le
contribuable qui a construit al le parc
nucléaire il a été construit par EDF
financé par EDF hein donc c'est c'est
oui c'est EDF qui a emprunté de l'argent
et qui l'a remboursé effectivement
effectivement il y a peut-être la
caution de l'État pour pour emprunter le
emprunter de l'argent aujourd'hui quand
euh parce que quand vous avez des
épisodes comme on a eu il me semble en
fin d'année dernière ou encore il
l'année précédente quand vous avez
beaucoup de vent ou beaucoup de soleil
et aujourd'hui notre parc nucléaire on
est une exception mondiale puisqu'on a
beaucoup d'électricité nucléaire 70 % et
donc on est obligé de la de la moduler
hein quand on a des creux de
consommation on est obligé de faire
baisser la la puissance et et quand et
quand on a des consommations qui
augmentent on augmente la puissance euh
et à cette modulation qui existait déjà
avant le développement chez nous des
énergies renouvelables intermittentes
donc on a depuis
2005 l'éolien et puis ensuite mis de du
photovoltaïque et bien ça
euh ça amplifié ce phénomène de
modulation est ce qui mis à l'arrêt des
réacteurs nucléaires quand vous les
arrêtez vous les réduisez vous vous
payez ça coûte le même prix si vous
voulez Paris que le coût le coût du de
l'uranium représente du coup fixe donc
vous payez le nucléaire et vous payez
l'olien vous payez de fois pour cette
raison que vous payis
voilà oui alors non mais juste sur les
questions que vous avez posé sur
peutêtre la la la demande demande RTE je
pense que ça c'est un point qui est très
important pour vous pour votre
commission
parce que RTE alors moi le souvenir que
j'ai c'est qu'au début des années 2010
RTE disait que la consommation allait
stagner ou baisser en électricité et au
début des années 2010 tout le monde leur
a dit qu'il racontait n'importe quoi
alors que ça allait augmenté qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé entre 2010 et 2020 la
consommation a baissé de 10 %. donc RTE
avait raison aujourd'hui effectivement
ils affirment parce que c'est aussi dans
les objectifs que la consommation va
augmenter avec le le développement de
l'industrie qui passe du gaz à
l'électricité avec l'électrification euh
du parc du parc automobile euh et
développement des voitures électriques
alors ce qu'on a peut-être moins
anticipé c'est que depuis un an ou deux
avec l'augmentation du prix de
l'électricité et bien ça fait baisser la
consommation qu'on a un certain nombre
d'industriels avec les prix du gaz deux
fois plus élevés euh qu'aux États-Unis
euh ben qui qui partent de France ça
fait aussi baisser la consommation donc
il va falloir regarder les différents
pans de de consommation pour voir
effectivement où ça va aller et pour
répononcier ce que vous disiez moi je
suis pas pro nucléaire ou je suis pas
pro renouvelablebl je suis pro
entreprise par contre et j'aimerais que
nos entreprises puissent continuer de
bénéficier des meilleurs prix de
l'électricité parce qu'aujourd'hui je je
vous le rappelle si vous ne le savez pas
nous sommes au niveau de défaillance des
PME de la crise financière de 2008 avec
400 PME qui font défaillances chaque
mois chaque mois donc mon l' enjeu est
plutôt et je pense que vous traiterez ça
dans votre commission l'enjeu l'enjeu
pour la France le principal enjeu c'est
de réussir à faire fonctionner les
centrales qui existent qui sont calqué
sur un modèle américain dont certaines
ont déjà été prolongé jusqu'à 80 années
de fonctionnement peut-être même 100
années l' en jeu aujourd'hui c'est de
voir eston en mesure de pouvoir
prolonger ce parc faire fonctionner ce
parc parce que c'est ça qui nous a posé
un problème en 2022 c'est qu'avec nos
problèmes de courision sous contrainte
on a produit 280 € 280 tawh alors que
d'habitude on en faisait plutôt
400 et alors vous m'avez posé 125 € du
mgawh c'est ce que paye le prix des
Français alors l'an dernier c'était pas
125 c'était 240 €in 240 euh puisque
c'était la recommandation de la
Commission de régulation de l'énergie le
1er le 19 janvier 2023 qui était que le
je vous parle que de la fourniture he
parce que si je parle tout le prix
d'électricité c'est plutôt 350 400 les
Français n'ont pas P ce prix là pourquoi
parce qu'ils ont eu le bouclier
tarifaire et donc l'état mais le
contribuable a compensé la différence
entre le tarif décidé par le
gouvernement et la recommandation de la
creux où est passé cet argent alors j'ai
une bonne nouvelle cet argent est passé
dans les poches
d'EDF c'est-à-dire qu'en 2023 eDF va
avoir 20 milliards d'euros d'bitda en
plus qui est un transfert direct du
contribuable français par le bouclier
tarifaire c'est une bonne nouvelle
puisque EDF comme vous le savez a fait
une perte en 2022 de 20 milliards
d'euros et a augmenté sa dette de 20
milliards d'euros donc cet argent va
principalement dans les poches de DF le
problème c'est que c'est au détriment
d'un certain nombre d'entreprises qui
elle nonont pas le bouclier tarifaire je
sais que récemment vous avez voté il y
avait un projet de loi de Philippe Brun
pour étendre le bouclier tarifaire à des
PME aujourd'hui c'est l'enjeu qu'on a et
qui n'est pas traité et qui n'est pas
réglé et qui n'est pas réglé avant 2026
comment est-ce qu'on fait pour nos TPE
avec plus de 36 kVA comment est-ce qu'on
fait pour toutes ces entreprises qui
restent bloqué encore un ou de ans avec
des contrats parle pas à 125 je vous
parle de 300 € du mgawh et qui n'ont
aucune porte de sortie de ces contrats
c'est ça l'enjeu et dans 2 ans si le
sujet n'est pas traité on va continuer à
en perdre 400 par
mois le dernier point c'était sur le
l'arène à 42 € non ça n'inclut pas le
renouvellement je pense que le tarif qui
été le calcul qui a été fait par la
creux est publié en septembre de 60 € du
ateur il me semble que celui-là inclut
le la prolongation et le et le nouveau
nucléaire merci Monsieur myan monsieur
pèin
Carlin pour revenir sur un sur un point
donc qui a été mentionné comme étant
comme quiéré deux fois effectivement il
y a des moments où la production
d'énergie renouvelable est tellement
importante et la demande tellement
faible que la production nucléaire
baisse de ce que moi j'ai vu dans les
données c'est de moins en moins le cas
dernière fois j'ai quelque chose de
dimensionnant c'était de mémoire en fin
des années 2010 j'ai oublié l'année
précise et donc une question que vous
pourriez poser
à moins que Monsieur M a la réponse mais
une question que vous pourriez poser par
exemple à RTE c'est combien d'heures par
an ce phénomène là arrive arrive
réellement de manière substantiel pour
voir s'il s'agit effectivement de
quelque chose de véridique mais de très
marginal ou quelque chose de de de très
dimensionnant deème point pour répondre
à une question qui qui avait été posée
auparavant en gros projetons-nous dans
une réalité alternative où soudainement
on décide de de couper les lignes
électriques entre la France et le reste
de l'Europe qu'est-ce qui se passe on a
beaucoup parler du prix mais je tiens et
je veux dire à rappeler ce qui serait
passé en 2022 c'est des blackouts
généralisés euh voilà faut être très
clair le premier bénéfice dont on a en
fait assez peu parl je me rends compte
je crois que vous l'aveiez évoqué quand
même le premier bénéfice du marché
européen de l'électricité c'est qu'on n
pas eu des blackouts généralisé en
France alors qu'on avait toute la
situation extrêmement difficile en en
2022 alors on peut toujours aller dans
cette réalité alternative dire non mais
on aurait déclenché plein de subventions
pour subventionner la construction
centrale à gaz comme on le fait
d'ailleurs pour une centrale à gaz gaz
en Bretagne effectivement euh mais
est-ce que l'État aurait eu la capacité
avec 10 ans d'anticipation de dépenser
de l'argent public pour
subventionner la construction centrale à
gaz voire à charbon ou ou ou à pétrole
et dans ce cas-là on aurait peut-être pu
éviter un coût économique extrêmement
important pour les Françaises et les
Français des des blackat donc ça c'est
vraiment un point central vous pouvez
éventuellement poser la question à RTE
d'estimer bah à tel moment combien de
millions de Français auraient été privés
d'électri ité si jamais on nait pas pu
importer 12 13 15 GW ce qui est
monumental de nos voisin européens voilà
un autre élément qui est aussi important
on parle beaucoup de l'Allemagne on a un
débat qui est très germanocentré en
France pour une raison que que que je
comprends mais qui parfois
scientifiquement
m'échappe l'intégration électrique entre
la France et l'Espagne elle est centrale
euh et elle est hyper bénéfique pour
plein de raisons je vais en mentionner
juste
deux le grand défi du secteur électrique
c'est de faire en sorte qu'on ait une
quasi égalité entre l'offre et la
demande pour éviter des modulations de
fréquence qui endommageraient le réseau
euh on peut le penser au niveau du jour
on peut le penser au niveau de l'année
et si on regarde en fait dans une
journée généralement le pic de
consommation traditionnellement en
France il arrive à l'heure du dîner un
petit peu avant le dîner autour de 192h
vous savez que les Espagnols dînent plus
tard mais du coup ce pic de consommation
en Espagne il arrive plus tard et du
coup cette différence culturelle entre
la France et l'Espagne est un bénéfique
électrique puisque le fait que les
Français dînent plutôt que les Espagnols
et qu'on est bien interconnecté tout ça
permet et aux Français et aux Espagnols
d'avoir un réseau plus stable et une
électricité légèrement moins chère il en
va de même au niveau de l'année en tout
cas pour l'instant puisque le changement
climatique a pas encore transformé le le
le le pic de consommation hivernale en
pic de consommation estivale mais le pic
de consommation d'électricité en Espagne
c'est durant l'été par durant l'hiver
donc là aussi il faut penser cette cette
intégration européenne qui encore une
fois à plein de désavantages et tout ce
qu' fait la Commission européenne n'est
pas papaaveddor euh mais qui globalement
est vraiment un élément très euh très
positif
euh trisème et avant dernier point si
jamais vous voulez explorer un élément
qui me semble intéressant que moi-même
j'ai pas exploré c'est ce qui se passe
dans les îles françaises donc là on a eu
un débat qui est très de France
continentale mais on n pas du tout eu de
dstructuration de DF sur sur les îles et
quand je dis les îles ça inclut les îles
bretonnes la Corse évidemment les les
dramcom euh regardons la situation
là-bas est-elle vraiment meilleure en
terme d'approvisionnement électrique
c'est pas c'est pas sûr et pourtant on a
EDF ESI qui est un système encore
complètement verticalement intégré donc
ça me semblera intéressant pas tout à
fait mais en tout cas qui qui est
beaucoup plus proche de voilà si on a un
cas on va dire disons que la la
politique de libéralisation électrique
de l'Union européenne a eu beaucoup
moins d'impact sur les îles françaises
que sur le continent français donc ça
peut faire un un élément intéressant de
de comparaison et je je terminerai du
coup aussi par vous encourager à à
inviter toute une série euh d'experts
là-dessus je pense à Nicolas Goldberg
Nadia maisi par exemple mais aussi à
essayer d'inviter des gens qui ont une
vision européenne il y a des Français
qui ont une vision européenne
Jean-Michel glachan euh qu'on connaît
bien euh ici mais aussi des gens qui
sont pas forcément français et qui
peuvent vous informer à la fois sur le
débats européens vous donner des points
de vuees qui permettent un peu de
décentrer euh notre regard euh je pense
à Leonardo bus par exemple qui est
l'Institut université européen de
Florence euh migoel Guil tertré qui est
le chef économiste de la dégénergie de
la Commission européenne ou encore
Christian Ruby qui est le lobbyiste en
chef du secteur électrique au niveau
européen ça me semble important aussi de
regarder ce qui se passe chez nos
voisins merci la situation est
différente mais je pense qu'on en a
beaucoup à en apprendre merci Monsieur
ping monsieur le rapporteur juste avant
de donner la parole à Monsieur desobri
mais par rapport à ce que vous venez de
dire là effectivement on est au début
des travaux de notre commission alors on
a 6 mois à peine 6 mois même avec les
Jeux Olympiques il faut essayer d'éviter
les les 15 jours de début juillet qui
seront pas forcément prop P à la sortie
d'un rapport sur l'électricité mais euh
donc ça veut dire que il y a beaucoup de
sujets on embrasse beaucoup de choses
qui trop emass mal les trains donc il
faut qu'on se méfie ceci étant dans ce
que vous nous avez dit il y a un certain
nombre de choses qui qui sont très
intéressantes et et ce qui se passe sur
les îles aussi peut nous intéresser
voilà il y a des choses à regarder euh
on a prévu d'aller à Bruxelles sans
doute de faire un déplacement à
Bruxelles on a prévu de voir pas mal de
personnes vous avez cité certains qu'on
a qu'on a déjà prévu de voir mais on est
preneur on vous remercie d'abord d'être
venu ce soir hein on va laisser la
parole aux deux derniers orateurs mais
on est preneur de vos retours de vos
informations de voilà de d'échanges dans
nos travaux voilà on a besoin de de
retour vous avez été auditionné vous
avez dit un certain nombre de choses
peut-être que vous avez pas pu tout dire
non plus euh vous avez pas pu apporter
tout ce que vous souaitiez apporter mais
on est on est à votre écoute et on est
voilà c'est pas terminé ce soir nos
travaux ne fut que commencer donc on
peut on peut continuer effectivement
avec vous et avec chacun d'entre vous
bien sûr monsieur président est-ce
est-ce qu'on peut demander une juste une
précision à ce qui vient d'êre dit non
pas sur lesffit tapass là qu'on vient de
nous expliquer entre la France et
l'Espagne mais ce que vous disiez
heureusement qu'on a eu le marché
européen parce qu'on a pu importer de
l'électricité don qu' qu'on avait pas
mais souvent il y a dans les analyses
politiques une confusion entre
l'ouverture à la concurrence et le fait
qu'il a européen parce qu'on pourra
avoir qu'un seul acteur national qui
achète de l'électricité à ses homologues
européens est-ce que ma question porte
sur est-ce que si on a acheté de
l'électricité à l'étranger est-ce
qu'elle coûtait plus cher et est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire maintenant o
est-ce que vous pourrez nous faire
passer le surcût lié aux importations à
ce
moment-là vous pouvez peut-être allumer
le j'ai une diapo qui qui montre en fait
le le prix de
l'importexort d'électricité permet en
fait justement d'harmoniser les prix euh
il y a des années où vous pouvez dire
effectivement que le marché
européenélectricité a augmenté les prix
de l'électricité en France au bénéfice
des recettes de DF clairement 2022 c'est
pas le cas c'est l'inverse qui s'est
passé euh l' 2022 ça a permis la baisse
d'électricité là vous avez la carte j'ai
pris j'ai fais ça dimanche à 11h donc
voilà j'ai pris j'ai pris au moment ces
prixl varient vous voyez que ce dimanche
à 11h on avait un prixélectricité
harmonisé sur on appelle la ptin
latérale donc France Allemagne c'est
souvent le cas qu'on a un prix qui est
soit exactement le même soit le même à
quelques centimes près il faut peut-être
dire qu'il y a des plaques de marché en
fait c'est c'est c'est c'est pas un
marché unique global alors c'est pas un
un marché unique et global si vousf on
peut on peut voir comme étant un marché
unique avec des plaques qui sont
interconnectées le point que je voulais
signaler par exle si vous si vous
regardez au sud de la Suède donc la la
Suède a cette spécificité d'être coupé
en quatre d'un point de vue V d'un point
de vue
électrique c'est ça et donc vous voyez
en fait au nord de la Suède un prix
extrêmement bas ce qui est une des
raisons pour lesquelles norsv qui est
une grande entreprise de production de
batterie ou gre qui fait de l'acier vert
c'est installé là-bas pourquoi est-ce
que c'est très bas là-bas parce qu'il y
a assez peu de d'habitants tout au nord
de la Suède mais ils ont beaucoup enfin
ils ont l'électricité qui est 100 %
renouvelable là-bas hydroélectrique plus
plus éolienne ce faible prix
d'électricité au nord de la Suède il
réussit à faire baisser le prix de
l'électricité directement au sud donc la
zone de Stockholm donc là vous voyez à
ce moment à 24 € qui permet aussi
lui-même de faire baisser le prix de
l'électricité euh dans le scyland donc
le le tout le sud euh le sud de la Suède
donc plus on a d'interconnexion plus ça
permet en fait de de que l'unité de
production la moins chère fasse baisser
le prix pour tout le monde après le le
grand goulot d'étranglement c'est
effectivement la connexion du réseau et
il y a un équilibre à trouver euh d'un
côté plus on interconnecte le réseau
plus on a des prix bas de l'électricité
sur le marché de gros mais en même temps
ça demande de faire plus de réseau et
plus d'investissement et donc il y a a
un juste milieu à trouver un optimum
économique pour l'instant je pense mais
monsieur des peut-être me contredira
mais je pense qu'il y a il y a besoin de
plus de réseau européens pour l'instant
après il y aura probablement un seuil de
développement de ce réseau-l à ne pas
dépasser pour pour garder du coup une
somme positive on va accélérer un peu
Martine Berté a demandé la parole je oui
merci beaucoup monsur des après alors
est-ce ça à dire que on n pas intérêt à
faire de l'effacement à demander de
l'EFF à nos industriels et à plutôt
favoriser les interconnexions pour faire
baisser le prix de l'électricité parce
que bon il me semblait quand même que le
principe de l'effacement alors ça c'est
pour le volume et la disponibilité
d'accord mais l'impact sur le prix
merci alors le l'impact de l'effacement
sur le prix est très positif on peut
tout à fait faire les deux et les deux
de mon point de vue sont même
complémentaires vous pouvez à la fois
interconnecter plus le réseau européen
et promouvoir ce qu'on appelle la la
flexibilité de la demande par de
l'effacement mais aussi on peut penser à
certains types de tarifs
euh électriqu euh qui peuvent permettre
aux gens de de les inciter à consommer à
certains moments plutôt qu'à plutôt qu'à
d'autres le tarif he plein or Creuse est
la la dimension la plus connue de ça
mais euh mais il y en a d'autres euh ces
angat de gestion de la demande sont
aussi de plus en plus intéressants au
fur à mesure qu'on a un développement
d'équipement qui consomme de
l'électricité mais qu'on peut pas besoin
de le faire en flux tendu pensez à à une
flotte de bus électrique dans une ville
vous avez pas besoin de charger 24 he 24
les bus vous pouvez le faire à certain
moment euh en règle générale en tout cas
chez moi dans le Calvados les bus
circulent plus en semaine que le weekend
et ben en règle générale en France le
weekend l'électricité est moins cher et
donc du coup ça augmente les chances que
ce bus électrique soit rechargé avec de
l'électricité moins cher et donc du coup
aussi plus décarboné puisque il y a il y
a il y a un lien entre les deux et donc
du coup plus on peut décaler la demande
dans le temps et la faire baisser mieux
ce sera pour les prix
d'électricité ça renvoie aux question de
Flex iibilité aussi ce que vous vez dire
on en reparlera dans
d'autres audition lors d'autres
auditions Monsieur dououri Vous AVEZ LA
PAROLE merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président juste peut-être deux remarques
pour
terminer c'est on voit que la la réforme
qui est engagée par la Commission
européenne elle tourne sur les contrats
à long terme et ça va être clé pour pour
déclencher les décisions
d'investissement dans les les les
centaines de milliards d'euros qui a qui
a dépensé sur sur sur sur l'énergie et
il y a une différence fondamentale dont
on n pas encore parlé entre les pipi qui
sont du coup des contrats privés et les
CFD qui sont des contrats
publics et la question de savoir si par
exemple on passe un CFD sur du sur du
nucléaire et du nucléaire existant dans
l'hypothèse où le prix de marché est
très bas le risque c'est que les
français payent le coût complet du
nucléaire quand les Européens payent le
coût marginal du nucléaire c'est-à-dire
que si on met le nucléaire sur le marché
de gros et que le marché de gros et à un
prix très faible notamment grâce à la
compétitivité du nucléaire l'Europe va
bénéficier d'unun d'une électricité très
compétitive à coût marginal très faible
de l'ordre de 10- 15 € alors que le
consommateur français via le CFD va
payer le coût complet du nucléaire et ça
c'est toute la difficulté du manque de
coordination au niveau européen où
finalement chaque État risque de
développer son propre dispositif et
éventuellement bah il y aura des
perdants et des gagnants et il faudrait
arriver à peut-être plus d'intégration
européenne à ce niveau-là pour être sûr
queah chaque bénéfice si les européens
bénéficient du parc nucléaire il payent
aussi pour le parc nucléaire français
dans l'hypothèse de de ce dispositif et
la la dernière remarque c'est le rôle
des fournisseurs on a on a beaucoup
parlé des des des fournisseurs
aujourd'hui et c'est vrai que dans le
projet de loi aujourd'hui qui est est
discuté sur la souveraineté énergétique
on parle des obligations prudentielles
du fournisseur et finalement les
obligations prudentielles des
fournisseurs ça repose la question de
l'intégration à mon aval des
fournisseurs c'est-à-dire est-ce que les
fournisseurs doivent pour sécuriser leur
propres clients et pour les sécuriser
face à la volatilité des prix du marché
est-ce que on doit leur imposer
finalement un certain niveau de
couverture soit par des contrats à long
terme soit par des investissements
directs qui pourrai mener dans des dans
des install de production et ça ça
répond à finalement une chose qu'on a on
se rend compte qu'aujourd'hui on a eu
raison de préserver l'intégration à mon
aval de DF probablement parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce modèle qui qui
peut-être préserve ou protège le mieux
les consommateurs face à la volatilité
des prix sur les
marchés merci Monsieur zour monsieur
Percebois oui monsieur le Président je
voudrais dire trois choses rapidement
revenir un peu sur la question de
Monsieur sénateur sur laaren moi j'étais
membre de la commission chambsort il est
clair que dans laarine c'est le coût du
nucléaire historique pas le coût du
renouvellement par contre il est prévu
qu'on tient compte de l'inflation et
qu'on tient compte également des coûts
d'entretien de ce nucléaire historique
bon alors la difficulté ensuite c'est
savoir si quand on tient compte des
cooups d'entretien du nucléaire
historique c'est pas une façon de le
prolonger alors ça c'est en effet une
autre question le deuxème point c'est le
débat qui a été soulevé tout à l'heure
sur 25 € le mgawh alors que on dit le
coût est à 80 125 € ça concerne la façon
de calculer le TRV par la creux le TRV
il est à peu près aujourd'hui en 2024 là
maintenant le 1er février il sera à 200
à peu près
280 28 centimes d'euros vous avez 44 %
c'est le coût de fourniture le reste
c'est les réseaux et les taxes sur les
44 % comment creux calcul 45 % c'est sur
la base de l'arène à 42 € donc les 55 %
c'est sur la base du prix gros sur les
derniers mois et donc c'est pas lié
directement au cours à l'instanté c'est
lié au prix des mois précédents al dire
pourquoi ben parce que beaucoup de
fournisseurs y compris d'ailleurs
parfois EDF les les mois précédents ils
ont acheté par avance cette électricité
et en 2023 ils l'ont payé un prix
beaucoup plus é d'ailles ils ont facturé
à le disent mais je comprends pas le
prix gros diminue et moi vous facturez
encore un prix plus élevé c'est
logique le fournisseur il s'est engagé
sur un prix plus élevé çaura pu être
l'inverse mais c'est ce qui se passe le
trè point qui para important c'est de
bien dissocier prix et coût normalement
en économie de marché les prix doivent
suivre les coût c'est la politique de
vérité des prix le problème c'est dans
les coûts il faut prendre le coût
complet et on prend pas toujours le coût
complet donc si je prends l'électricité
le coût complet ça comprend bien sûr le
coût de production mais vous avez les
externalités on en a beaucoup parlé vous
avez des externalités négatives qui sont
prises en compte le CO2 c'est un bon
exemple le carbone est pris en compte
c'est une externalité les centrales
fossiles paient l'externalité négative
est-ce que c'est le bon niveau c'est une
autre
question mais vous avez des externalités
négatives par exemple les renouvelables
elles sont soumises à l'intermittence
donc c'est une externalité négative
alors dire oui mais c'est pour la bonne
cause ça veut bien dire qu'il faut du
backup alors la solution peut être
réglée si lorsque le prix de
l'électricité est très bas avec ses
renouvelables vous fabriquez de
l'hydrogène que vous stockez que vous
faites de l'électricité ensuite bon pour
l'instant c'est pas très très rentable
bon enfin c'est une solution à terme
vous avez une autre externalité moi j'ai
travaillé là-dessus c'est l'effet
d'éviction arrêter une centrale
nucléaire pour laisser passer des
renouvelables c'est un coûte donc c'est
un élément à prendre en compte vous avez
un élément de coût très important qui
est jamais mentionné parce qu'il est
très difficile à évaluer c'est ce qu'on
appelle le coût système pour l'équilibre
du réseau il faut des machines
tournantes pour équilibrer en permanence
l'offre et la demande et les machines
tournantes ce sont soit des centrales
qui utilisent des énergies fossiles soit
le nucléaire parce que si vous voulez
c'est c'est le système ça c'est un
problème de physique donc ça c'est un
élément également à prendre en compte
alors vous avez des coûts qui sont
mutualisés on a parlé toutes les
énergies en profitent toutes les
centrales en profitent les coûts de
réseau par exemple souvent ils sont
mutualisés on dit ben le coût de
raccordement de l'éolien ou le coût de
raccordement du solaire euh enédis parce
que là il y a des coûts très important
de réseau les cûts de réseau vont
augmenter le prochain élément qui va
perturber la facture du consommateur
c'est les coûts de réseau ça a déjà été
le cas dans les années 2010- 2020 et
demain la note elle va monter à cause
des coups de réseau ces cûps-l ils sont
mutualisés alors vous allez me dire mais
pourquoi on mutualiserait pas ces coups
on l'a bien fait pour le nucléaire quand
vous construisez une centrale nucléaire
le coup de raccordement il est mutualisé
dans le coup de transport surtout à
l'époque où il y avait un opérateur
unique donc je crois que le point
important c'est de bien et dresser la la
bonne typologie je dirais des différents
coûts en sachant que la préoccupation
c'est quel est le quel est le juste prix
par rapport au coût complet de chaque
type de centrale merci merci Monsieur Je
je je je voudrais vous poser une
peut-être une une dernière question euh
je sais que vous avez étudié la la
question du financement des
investissements à venir grand carénage
réseau et cetera et vous vous mettez en
présence quatre modes d'accès au marché
financiers pour financer ses
investissements les fonds souverains
c'est-à-dire l'État qui emprunte et
cetera des taux voilà à
priori favorabl entre guillemet en tout
cas plus plus favorable que si on est
dans un système que vous qualifiez
vous-même de de barre d'actifs régulés
ensuite de contrat pour différence et et
finalement de PPA qui serait le
dispositif le plus onéreux en terme
d'accès au d'accès au marché financier
pour financer ces investissements vous
pourriez nous en dire deux mots parce
que c'est un sujet qui à terme
évidemment va avoir un impact direct sur
ce qui nous intéresse à savoir le prix
que va que va payer le le le
consommateur quoi le consommateur final
vous pourriez nous dire deux mots s'il
vous plaît merci traditionnellement
c'est le producteur qui s'end dette al
c'était le modèle EDF n'oublion pas que
le parc nucléaire français a été financé
par emprunt sur le marché américain très
largement le marché français financier
était très étroit à l'époque donc sur
hord du gouvernement EDF empruné sur le
marché américain comme EDF était un
épique que EDF emprunte c'est l'état
français qui emprunte donc le risque
était très faible pour pas dire nul et
donc les coûts d'emprunt ont été
relativement bon avec un petit bémol
quand même c'est qu'EDF a emprunté quand
le cours du dollar était bas et a
remboursé on commencé à rembourser quand
le cours de dollar à monté on a emprunté
quand cours du dollar valait 4 francs
français on rebourse quand il vaut 10
francs bon c'est pas une excellente
affaire mais bon on a emprunté ça c'est
le premier système le deuxème système en
effet c'est le système in point
c'estàdire le contrat pour différence
donc l'État garantit en quelque sorte
que une fois que la centrale sera
opérationnelle et bien l'opérateur
bénéficiera d'un prix régulé pendant une
certaine période 35 ans une clim point
92 livres sterling par mgaw de l'époque
et donc etedfc que l' aura 92
€ livres sterling par mgaw alors si le
prix du marché de gros est à l'époque on
a dit mais c'est énorme sauf qu'on
savait pas que les prix du marché de
gros allaient monter donc si le prix de
gros est au-delà de 92 et ben euh à ce
moment-là si vous voulez euh EDF donnera
la différence par contre si le prix de
gros est en dessous c'est l'État
britannique qui versera la différence
l'inconvénient du système c'est qu'EDF
ne commence à percevoir des recettes
qu'au moment où la centrale est
raccordée au réseau le troisième système
alors en effet c'est le système sizewall
c'estàd le système de la prochaine
centrale avec le gouvernement
britannique donc à ce moment-là c'est un
système de base d'actifs régulé c'est un
peu comme les réseaux c'est-à-dire qu'on
récupère au fil de l'eau donc eDF n'a
pas à attendre
que la centrale soit opérationnelle pour
commencer à avoir des recettes alors qui
prend le risque et qui paye bah c'est
clair c'est le consommateur he c'est
dire qu'à ce momentlà le consommateur
dès le début en quelque sorte participe
au financement donc ça c'est un bon
système système de base d'actif régulé
c'est ce qui se passe pour les réseaux
chaque
année on fixe le Turp le tarif
d'utilisation des réseaux public
d'électricité la creux dit quel est le
bon chiffre c'est le c'est du Coste plus
on connaî les coûts et on fixe le prix
le 4è système en effet au aujourd'hui
qui va probablement se développer c'est
de passer des des pipier en puissance
pas en énergie avec des opérateurs qui
sont prêts à participer au financement
alors c'est pas tout à fait le modèle
Exeltium parce que Exeltium c'est un
modèle en mgawh c'est pas un modèle en
mgaw par contre c'est le système qu'on
trouve en Finlande don dont je parlais
tout à l'heure alors ce système il a un
gros avantage c'est que vous avez un
gros fournisseur ou un gros client
industriel évidemment que c'est pas un
petit consom Atur qui va accepter ça qui
dit je suis prêt à participer au
financement d'une centrale exemple c'est
ce que Total a fait savoir total
ennergie a dit moi je suis prêt à
participer au financement partiel d'un
réacteur moyenant
évidemment des droits de tirage alors
évidemment l'opérateur à ce moment-là
prend des risques en même temps que le
constructeur parce que Total est prêt à
prendre des risques évidemment il faut
un un opérateur qui qui a une surface
financière élevée la question c'est on
il semble qu's souhaite le faire pour
beaucoup d'électrointensifs est-ce que
beaucoup d'électrointensifs auront les
moyens de faire les avances de liquidité
ça c'est une question qui est ouverte
c'est pas
évident merci Monsieur perscebois Merci
monsieur de zobri Monsieur pèin Carlin
monsieur
Man pour cet échange pour sur un sujet
compliqué tu veux dire de mots non bon
écoutez mer beauoup on poursuit demain
nos travaux et on vous remercie merci on
reviendra peut-être vers vous sur sur
certains sujets
merci